what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos as you guys already know if
you have watched two or more of my lives
and you do not subscribe we have beef
okay beef people
um guys make sure you like the video
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these videos um
we want to get at least a thousand likes
on the video okay a couple announcements
before we start the show the first is
that we have two clips channels the
first is just pearly clips and the
second is Pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both
um next we have four membership tiers
the first tier you get to be a part of
our live chat tonight the second tier
you get to see are behind the scenes
Vlogs and our Discord third tier you get
to connect with me on social media and
our fourth tier you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month I really
recommend this if you guys want to learn
about starting a live show
um I have helped people on social media
so you definitely should sign up if you
want to do that
um
guys they took away my Instagram
I know
um it's been taken away for like a month
now but I made a new one it's just
pearly things one so you should go um
follow that and also go follow me on
Tick Tock just pearlythings.5 and just
pearly things six
um also guys a lot of you have been
telling me to get on Rumble and I just
found out today we are in fact on Rumble
so the link to that is in the
description go subscribe to our new
channel live school we're going to be
turning 304s into wives out here so if
you want to see that live subscribe to
wife school
um also
um I just started another Channel which
is Pearl behind the scenes basically I
used to do reaction videos all the time
um just with like a computer by myself
and I would just like stream for a
couple hours and I miss doing that um
more like behind the scenes look so I'm
gonna start doing those again so go
subscribe to that channel
um if you want to come on the show DM DM
the pregame show podcast on Instagram
and super chats are going it towards a
back camera and also getting blessing a
monopod to increase the quality of our
street interviews that's it so today we
have a lovely panel so why don't we go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and a fun fact
about yourself if you want
so starting here go around and then you
can do the second row
hi I'm Naomi
um fun fact about myself
um I am a former bodybuilder but not
with the big muscles bikini athletes and
I gave the app a few years ago
hi guys obviously the novel Troublemaker
extraordinaire
uh I am we were on the same side this
week right on Instagram I yeah listen
fun fact me and Paul know how to agree
sometimes yes I am 29 20 30 Wednesday
7th of December lucky number seven simwa
I am single free not really ready to
mingle and say well that's me
hi guys I'm back I'm 25 I'm single and a
fun fact about me is I'm a vegan and I
haven't ate meat in about 16 years wow
16 years that's impressive hey guys my
name is Hannah I'm um 20 I'm single and
ready to mingle and a fun fact about me
is I am a power lifter yeah
oh what does that mean I lift heavy
things
squat definitely I always wanted to do
power lifting I wanted to deadlift oh
dad left is deadly though like it's
scary
go ahead yeah you and then hi um my name
is Luca I'm also 20 and single
um and like backs I'm vegan as well so
yeah
um my name is Ola I'm 34 in a five year
long relationship and interesting thing
about me um professionally I'm a lawyer
but I want to be a writer so I've
written a book trying to get it
published
good evening everyone my name is Pierre
um I'm a Nomads you see me when you see
me
um and I'm single
foreign
29
what's good is your boy Josh
um
um 20
um
uh relationships I'm single and um fun
fact for me
I've been a chef for five years and it's
all gone and you said you're 20. yeah so
you've been a chef since you're 15.
correct wow
uh it's kind of people I'll go about
beard gang I'm 28 taken and as you know
I've been connecting bids since 2019.
same one every time okay
um so um today is today's topic is um
post walls 304s give bad in my advice
question mark
um so today we are going to be reacting
to Mia Khalifa
[Music]
um
yeah um I think we should just start
with the video I feel like that's the
best way to do it
you gotta click the sound thing on the
yeah
that's not how it was it wasn't just hey
do you want to come do porn it was more
so oh you're beautiful like would you
like to do some modeling no you have a
great body like I think you'd be great
nude model it
I'm sorry I think I sent him the wrong
clip one second one second
um foreign
she doesn't have that normal cone stuff
look does she she said corn as well yeah
and she sounded like she was coerced
into it honestly
coerced like the way she was like I was
told like I was good at modeling and
then it was nude modeling and then it
was porn like it sounded like okay
well that one escalated quickly from
modeling I'm not gonna lie
um sorry I thought I totally thought
that was the other clip
um if anyone can you guys send me the
one on Instagram I think Rolo reacted to
it
um do you want to just do the Andrew
Tate one and then we'll find the other
one
um
yeah
the reason 18 and 19 year olds are more
attractive than 25 year olds is because
they've been through less dick I'll say
this right here on the [ __ ] internet
I don't give a [ __ ] people sit there and
go oh you can't say that yes I can a 19
year old is more attractive than a 26
year old woman and I'll tell you why
because that 26 year old has talked to
more guys been to the club more times
been more places been [ __ ] and dumped
more times more arguments more
heartbreak more [ __ ] more mess for
me to clean up whereas a 19 year old
might have had one guy from high school
just broke up she's fresh and I can
[ __ ] put my imprint on her make her a
good person and without her having to go
through all that detriment to learn
about life
okay so my first question
how old are you and what age range do
you date
I won't reveal my age
but I can tell you my most recent ex I
was with him on and off four years and
there was a big age difference he
I think he was 27 26 27 this year so
um yeah so I will I would date between
mid-20s and
I'll go from 25 to 55. 20 wow that's a
huge rain yeah enjoying yeah so I I can
either date you or your dad or the other
way around
okay uh I am
29 minus a week uh no 30 minus a week
apologies and I date probably
up to five years older than me Max I
think
so you won't go like if you guys 40
that's too old
he's a fine 40 year old
hmm
five years okay that's a hard note wait
but you also didn't mention younger
though like you just I don't well
younger maybe Max two years younger Max
the tight tight window for me
I'm 12 I'm 25. I
wouldn't do younger anymore but Max I
would do
I think round 30s is good for me
um maybe just a bit over like
32 33.
yeah oh yeah I'm 20. I would date up to
25 just because I haven't got my life
sorted yet and I don't want someone
that's that's got everything sorted out
yeah yeah
okay
um I'm 20 and I would probably date from
like 19 to
um like a hard cap maybe like 35. okay
uh I'm 34 and I would say so my
girlfriend like she's like mid-20s so
the bottom end would be mid-20s and top
end would be around late 30s 40 like 30s
40 mm-hmm
I'm 29 and the bottom absolute bottom is
the 90s baby so 99
[Music]
um
um and the top end just depends on the
person
and where I am in life
um so 45 you're in she looks good I'll
be honest with you I've seen some I've
I've seen some I've seen all sorts that
look good so okay so so 50 55. there's
got to be a rough cap I'm just saying a
rough cap a rough cap yeah rough cap
um obviously JLo was an exception
for me it's a thing it's a combination
of things of course life I'm in the
Dayton space
and I don't know if she's 50 but she
looks she doesn't look like the 50s that
Society call 50 year olds then you know
I'm not gonna okay anyone that looks
good yeah okay okay but running off what
Andrew Tate said like doesn't she have
too much baggage
are we talking about dating or
commitment here well so tell me about
that's a big difference tell me both
yeah so someone you'd want to take
seriously long term and someone you go
for a short term
someone long term now
um I can't I can't start a family of a
50 year old
um
no there's some some 50 euros out there
but not for me it's not it doesn't work
for me um but isn't the aim of dating
like like long-term relationships or is
it just like kind of fun depends on your
accent
I'm not I'm not I don't I don't
personally date for fun I do I do
commitments
um so
if I'm looking to get married to someone
then I'm going to be thinking about my
family and who I can build something
with yeah so like you'll enjoy being
with a 50 year old like exchanging
conversation but like you wouldn't like
it wouldn't be serious you know I mean
like it would just be kind of I don't
know like understanding them meeting
them but not like it would never be a
long time yeah maybe a little kiss here
and there yeah no I feel like just just
for the purpose of the question but it's
just purely for the purpose of the
question but I think if it came to a
commitment scenario
um a couple years above me at most
um but I'll probably look down as
opposed to up yeah that's just how I
view dang like I view it as something
that like I'm always seeing if you could
fit into my life like long term because
otherwise it's just gonna hurt my
feelings yeah I think that's typically
more of a female view yeah can I qualify
my answer that I just get basically yeah
so like the upper end I literally just
said 40 like romantically if you look
good there's no reason why it can't even
be Beyond four eight the only reason why
I cap it at 40 because I presume you're
probably in a different stage of life
that I'm in and there might be a
lifestyle Mitch mismatch that's the only
reason but even then I could discover
that's not the case and then I'd be
willing to As Long As I you look good to
me I'm still attracted to you well good
I sorry to interrupt but um I think Ages
were irrelevant I mean there's there's a
limit to what I would go down to
see 25 is the lowest I will go
um but I think you could be this is from
a woman's point of view to men you could
be missing out from a really great woman
just because you put these restrictions
on ages and it's not all about you know
it's popping out babies it might be you
might find the woman the love of your
life for any they could be any age you
don't have to be popping babies out but
you could miss out for for amazing long
you know lifelong partner with all your
restrictions that's just my personal
point of view but you kind of
contradicted yourself because you said
age is irrelevant but then you said you
wouldn't go under 25.
like like what's wrong with the 24 year
old that's got his stuff together okay
yeah I said 25 but yeah if it's a 24
year old but I'm not gonna go I'm not
gonna go really low because that's not
relevant for me and I know I'm not
saying how old I am but yes I understand
I apologize for if you felt a
contradiction myself but yeah there
there is a limit but an upper limit you
could be missing out on a great man or a
great woman I agree would you do the guy
that was 90.
it could be 110 treats me well just
wants to take me out to dinner and have
some company buy me nice things but you
still have to be respectful
yeah I I I I I agreed with you to a
certain extent given I think ultimately
it comes down to your intention
so if you're if your intention is to
actually have a family I think there's a
biological clock that we can't
necessarily Overlook and you may say
like there's also yeah there are options
adoption and so forth but not every man
May necessarily want to take that route
so my response was for an effect of my
version of a commitment where I am in my
life
I need to be with a woman that can I can
have a family with
and
with my age currently speaking
the higher up I go
I guess if I want more than one child or
so forth that kind of has to be
accelerated and as a man
you know you've got a you've got to kind
of plan these things up but the planning
also takes time so you know there's a
point when I'm not sure it's different
for different women's but from what I've
learned in school
there's a point where women can't
provide families no no I understand that
and I have a very
calm point of view when it comes to
Children I'm not going to go there now
um
I am a support person to my best friend
who's a Foster carer and I've seen the
value of fostering adoption there are
thousands of children in this country
who would benefit from having an amazing
loving home and when you look at things
differently this is just my personal
point of view and it's no attack on
anyone here but when you look at the
children that don't actually have a home
and you've got everyone popping out
these babies I get it people say oh I
want I want blood that has to be my
blood my child but if you actually look
into it whether it's adoption or okay
fostering's different for a short time
but adoption it doesn't matter where
it's whether it's blood or not the
problem is there's a lot of problems
that come with adoption like there's a
lot of issues like if you don't get the
kid before the age of three like it's
fully developed and any issues that it
had before the age of three a lot of
times you can't stop
um and I'm not I'm not like against
adoption but I just think sometimes it
it can a lot of people aren't aware of
how hard it is when they go into it and
this is as someone like I have three
adopted siblings
no no I I totally understand that and
um I have friends
um her adopted children as well but also
it depends on
the type of person you are what parent
you will be
um
the type of child there's so many
different variations it's just kind of
like if a guy could avoid that headache
of like like you'd have to find find the
kid hopefully it's like coming out of a
not too bad situation
um and like pain it's really expensive
too in the US I don't know how it is
here but you have to pay ten plus
thousand dollars per kid it's like why
would he go through that headache no you
don't do that here adoption goes through
oversea you know are they free here it
is it is free you go through your local
Council or adoption services and you
don't have to pay for that and over
interject I you do have to make a
certain amount of money to provide for
the child you're not allowed to just
adopt a child with no money of course of
course so ideally you're financially
stable anyway for any child if you're
gonna get pregnant or you're gonna adopt
money is in the equation because you
have to provide a living so it's a
complete deterrent for going for older
women for guys I guess but what about
the women that like you if like scenario
that you find that your dream girl
you're in love with her and when you
find that like she can't provide a
family for you no matter how old she is
then you have to go through adoption
anyway so why is like age a hard cap I
think it's just like likelihood I mean
like geriatric pregnancy starts at 35.
um 90 90 of your eggs are gone by 30.
yeah and so it's just like if if you get
a 25 year old or 22 year old that's less
likely to happen but there's like
there's still that chance that she's
like completely infertile you know what
I mean so like I don't know in my eyes
like
it's a chance though it's like if you're
going for an older woman then it's more
likely so it's kind of it's not a waste
your time it's kind of like okay if you
pick two roads on the highway and one
has an accident every week and one and
one it's usually fine like which one are
you gonna pick yeah
um okay you too
okay
um can you repeat the question um so how
old are you so you're 20. yeah and
what's the age range you date
um so younger
um by two years
older
three max oh wow okay three max because
two I mean I'm just doing long term so
yeah okay
um I'm 28
um if I'm taking it serious
uh looking for something long term then
my market would be 21 to 32.
if I'm just outside in the field having
fun then
20 to 50 I'd say
in the field outside shooting shots
um what's the oldest I've dated beard
gang
uh 49. what was that like
interesting so I was just like 21 at the
time so it was a good experience does
the woman feel different at that age a
lot different yeah how
I don't know because I'm not that age
yet so I don't know
I don't know if it was because I was
young but I'd say it's just a level of
assurance
you know I've kind of dated around that
age and I would say they're just more
interesting like they have a lot more
life experience and it's a different
kind of relationship they're like your
guider like your Mentor more no for me
it was more like cougar Vibes
you're just taking advantage of a 21
year old yeah and what was your benefit
in that just the reassurance you felt
like mummy
there's a bonus points in it it's like
it's like I'm starting to go into your
friends about the time I mean okay so
I've done it so go ahead oh yeah I've
done that before as well like when I was
in my early 20s I went out with uh I was
seeing a woman who was like mid-30s like
maybe like my age now like 34. and um
for me the benefit was she was so
emotionally mature and she knew herself
and there was like this confidence in
her and like I'm not
I wouldn't say I'm the most I'm
I find it difficult to deal with just
insecurities and the idea of making
your insecurities something someone else
has to wrestle with and that's just the
part of a relationship we all do it but
I feel like with her she had dealt with
it wrestled with it and had coping
mechanisms too like pull her through it
and there was so much I learned from her
in that regard of like okay this is what
it looks like when you kind of take care
of your own [ __ ] okay yeah when you take
care of your own [ __ ] and so it was kind
of like um it was a really good
experience in that regard for me I think
for her it was like one question yeah
relationship work out like why did you
end up leaving oh because like dude I
think like I I think for her it was
there was a bit of a play aspect to it
like she didn't take me that seriously
and to be fair I wasn't to be I wasn't
to be taken seriously at that age or
time but um we Vibes really well and she
I think even just the idea of what a
woman can contribute to your life
outside of being beautiful and looking
good like just being stimulated mentally
like by her and her life experiences
like you said like it kind of shaped
what I look for dating going forward can
I say something quickly oh God
I'll let you go so basically
as a woman grows older maybe past the
age of like 26 27 they start to have a
better mentality less insecurity less
headaches a bit more maybe grounded in a
bit more self-sufficient when it comes
to emotional stability and yet we're
trying to say that it's easier maybe
perhaps or better for men to go for 19
year olds we're women over 30 generally
are just way more calm yeah anyone over
30s well I'm gonna say about 20 30. so I
to answer your question I actually don't
think it's just a women thing I think
it's everyone but I think as you develop
and you grow you become more sure of
yourself so now I'm right for the
picking type of thing yeah maybe for
some people I'm not saying everyone in
their 20s is immature or not ready or
whatever but I think generally speaking
in your 20s you're trying to figure it
out in your 30s you know who you are
because you know yourself and you've
learned to like yourself and you've
learned what you're struggling with yeah
I think when you reach that age you just
had so much experience and I'm just
saying like as for me I don't want to
experience your experience so I wouldn't
me personally I wouldn't take anyone
over that age seriously because you come
with a lot of baggage and me personally
if I'm gonna take you seriously in in if
you're like 20 years plus more than me
you you you have a lot of experience
that you're gonna compare me to so if I
lack in one field you'll be like in the
back of your mind you'll be like oh but
when I was dating so and so he used to
buy me all these gifts I'm used to
getting these so it's like I'm not
really trying to go through all that um
how old are you again I'm 20. yes you
like when I was your age I used to feel
guilty like if I was dragging it on for
too long because I feel like you know
what I don't I can't see this long term
because of the age Gap and then I feel
guilty like dragging it on because I
feel like I'm wasting your time Chris do
you guys feel like older women
um okay I had a guy tell me once that if
he dated a girl under the age of 25 he
didn't have to worry as much about that
because she wasn't like dying for a tip
for commitment but if she was over the
age of 25 like they want to settle down
like they want to lock you down quicker
that's true yeah 100 no all right same
no no no no
yeah I'm out guys wait wait I'm asking
the guys because they date women so I
mean to be fair I think I think when it
comes to all the women right and I just
think from my experience like when I I
like no I did long term seriously but
obviously you know back in the day your
boy had a little sprinkler around the
field but um one thing
I was I was I was sprouting very early
from 16 onwards but one thing I realized
about
um these uh older women is that it it's
kind of they're more on the I I don't
see it on the side where they take it
serious because once they see a younger
guy they don't usually see me as a
serious candidate as for a long-term
relationship they just want some quick
action and they just want to feel young
again you know what I mean so like I
know when I used to get in those um
situations the fact that
since I was so young and I guess the way
how I would compliment them make them
feel make their bodies feel like there's
a Temple they they they live off of that
stimulation because I'm I'm overly
praising them in such a sense so the
fact that I made them feel younger they
know that I'm not going to get this as a
long-term relationship and I made that
clear from the start but they just
really enjoyed the fun they was getting
a little bit like that and I think the
the common denominator of every story is
that you were young and in your 20s in
your early 20s so I think that shows a
level of manipulation was maybe they're
like they know that you're young and
naive and you're like latch on because
it's fun you know normally
division but like they know you're young
and like like you're impressionable yeah
you'll enjoy the validation of being
with them almost like because like no
one said oh when I was in my like late
like when I was in my uh like late 20s
or early 30s I was with someone who was
like 50 because because you know
yourself better and you know that that's
not something you could maybe commit to
so who who has manipulated him or her no
like not manipulator but like are you as
your younger so if you don't know
yourself as well maybe so like you're
kind of like oh like this older person
likes me like oh like that's cool like I
I think that might be slightly different
because I think I think when in the
woman's perspective because she's the
younger one and she's the older guy
maybe yeah maybe from my perspective I
know that when I was in that stage trust
me I just know I wanted to release one
yeah I didn't feel manipulated I
have a question for you guys
is it wrong
for what age do I want to do a 32 year
old man to date an 18 year old no nope
no I judge him for it okay if anyone
says raise your hand if you think yes
all right I'm gonna raise my hand no I
need a yes or no yes or no come on
everyone grows up at different ages okay
it depends okay
what depends what she's listening she
looks I don't know an 18 some of them
look like they're 18 when they're 13.
because you're like how old did you say
it was he's 32 she's 18.
all right at 32.
when you sit down with an 18 year old
what are you talking about like what is
she like no for real like generally what
is she offering you like and I mean if
she's okay I mean
you're just a baby I feel yeah you're
just talking about one dimension and I
look at you and I'm like all right you
as a man let's say you have stuff in
common let's say like maybe maybe you're
into the same stuff maybe they're both
Gamers I don't know okay and that's
that's off the top of my head I'm like
it's not in of itself wrong but I do
raise an eyebrow because I do Wonder
like like you question the guy a little
bit I questioned the guy a little bit
like what do you like because all right
I'm he's seriously dating or is he just
having fun like in your scenario uh
let's say let's say seriously dating
okay so you've looked at this he's
looking for a wife all right cool and so
I'm here and I'm like so in this 18 year
old who is like a few years off from
being a child you're like in you I see a
partner and someone I want to build and
someone I want to model my potential
daughters after all that I really and
I'm like bro like off an 18 year old it
kind of depends though if if she's like
someone that's been like working out
there enough like living by herself
independent then you kind of because a
lot of women mature a lot quicker as
well
you could have an 18 year old that
literally acts like a 25 year old you
don't even know anything yeah so it
depends on it like some 18 year olds are
in uni yeah and they're basically kids
yeah that's what I'm thinking it's like
you're right it kind of depends on it
that's why I struggled to put my hand up
yeah but it's like it's because
sometimes you're like oh she's 18 and
she's in uni and she's only lived with
her parents and she's coming out and
you're visiting her dormant yeah big man
she wants a family maybe she's 18 yeah
okay but it's still the same Dimension
we're talking about looks infertility
that's it that's what you pick your
partner right I got something in common
they've got something in common I just
struggled to with the idea that an 18
year old girl in uni is stimulating your
mind and spirit like and if she is I
kind of I just think like when I was 18
versus 21 like I wasn't that different
like I'm just I'm just thinking like
mentally I don't think I was that
different at 18 from 21. I don't think
there is that much difference yeah and
no one would really bat an eye at 21. no
I I moved out when I was 18 and I was
working so I was I was you know pretty
much a full-grown adult at 18. all right
denelva tell me why why is it now and
then when you go next why why is the
problem yeah and all the man I think
it's really down to the different stages
of emotional maturity and growth when
you're 18 although yes you can be mature
in this and that but you've not
experienced the how many extra 14 years
extra of life that he has experienced he
has that over you and I think that it's
not about manipulation it's just about
the point the fact that there'll be a
certain moment in both of their lives
where you're just going to realize we're
not on the same level we're not in the
same frequency and that's really
important that's what do you mean in the
same because a lot of times we use these
words I don't even know what they mean
this in the same frequency yeah the same
frequency meaning like okay when you're
now 40 I'm just about to turn 30. in
like five every five years I I feel like
every five years I go through quite a
lot of change you know you especially
then with decades you look back on your
life and you think about so many things
you reflect and your mind may change
that's why you can see the difference
between a 20 year old woman and a 30
year old woman so I just think is a bit
dangerous when you're kind of dealing
with somebody that's so far away from
where you're at at your age so for
example for me that's why I say I'll
date somebody that is younger than me by
two years Max and Max five years older
because I don't want it to be too far
away do you think there's a limit to
your pool a little bit
um I I think that at this point I'm more
just looking for the right person and
from what I know about myself I feel
like what I need is that limit
okay um what do you think
um yeah I think an 18 year old obviously
there's different kinds of 18 year olds
but they've got a lot of
experiences to go for I think a 32 is a
bit old I think like 28 29 is fine but
why would a and maybe you guys can
answer that you men why would a 32 year
old want an 18 year old is it just
because she's more likely to be a virgin
and
is that the main reason why you would go
for one because I wouldn't like
be like uh but I'd be a bit confused
like why wouldn't you go for someone
who's maybe like mid-20s or like even 21
like what's the reason I don't know yeah
I think I think it's wild to be honest I
wouldn't like legit so I can't can I can
I just make a side note on this
um not that I agree with the Fate 2 and
and the 18 year old but
I I feel like it comes down to the
individual yeah I've come across 40 year
olds 50 year olds that'll in many cases
less mature than 18 year olds
so and I think it goes both way
irrespective of your gender
um but what was your question just in
terms of that well I wanted to know what
the what would be the reason for that
would it just be because she's likely to
have less bodies as that the main reason
um
cool
um because like initially what I do
think of it 30 to 18 yeah that is a
pretty big like Gap and I would like
look at it a type of way
but I feel like
if we come to a common agreement on what
a guy is usually looking for and what a
girl is usually looking for they kind of
meet each other where they need you know
I mean because
I hope you guys can agree well but um
you know men very I value beauty and I
value youth fertility so if I'm at the
age of 32
sure I could go for someone 25 26 but I
think like nowadays most of those women
already they're very like
career driven they're very they have
like this past bit mentality so I feel
like they're gonna be way more combative
than the 18 year old because I feel like
if she comes into this
um
space
she's gonna value
that I reach this point and then she's
going to be more agree agreeable with me
because then I I can also like teach her
okay I want to say teacher but you can
guide someone that's older is more set
in their ways exactly yeah 100 so I just
feel like this 18 year old maybe she has
she's as matures I mean I would say it's
the same thing like if you date an older
guy and you try to change him you're mad
like why would you if you if I dated a
50 year old I'm expecting him to change
after 50 years of living his life one
way exactly that's all they know so it's
like the younger you go because
obviously most of the time 18 year old
is gonna look
um better than 26 28 year old so it's
like if I value that then and I see that
they can agree to me what I want to do
long term it's like why why not choose
that instead of okay so I have a
question so we're talking about changing
people so in this scenario in in the
scenarios I usually posed we're talking
about the fact that there's a need to
change a woman because obviously he's
older he's going to be set in his way so
the man is cool we always just have to
assume that Amanda is 30 is mature in
doing his thing all the time and he can
take care of a 18 year old woman and
murder to be what he wants when in fat
people he doesn't even know what he
wants exactly so I think it's really
quite dangerous to play that game and if
it were to twist to turn the the the
story and make it I don't think it's
good to influence the person you're with
like you don't want a guy that you can
follow
yeah but I also want a guy that can also
follow me too because I'm not just going
to be adapting to someone on my own so
you want to follow and then he follows
yeah I want us to grow together yeah I
want it to be like this but I think it's
a dangerous game playing with the idea
we want to change people like you're
dating someone because you like them
you're not dating them because you see
potential and you want to manipulate
them I think relationships compromise
yeah yeah so I just think like that I
just think if you're the person
um I looked up political ideologies this
is seems off topic but I have a point
um when I was younger because I was
curious like what makes people change
their minds and like what things
influence them and the number one thing
that influences your political ideology
over time is your partner like you kind
of rub off on the person you're with
yeah I agree the longer you're with
someone the more you become like them
and you agree because you want to be
familiar you want to be the same to them
that's not necessarily a good thing but
yeah to answer my girl's question that
would be the reason why a guy would
that's 32 is going to go for 18 year old
if so he can mold her into the girl that
he was agreeable exactly yeah don't you
think that people should like as they're
like so young they're 18 like don't you
think they should find their own way in
life like yeah like thinking a 32 year
old might be helpful for them and like
working out these life like problems and
stuff and like fight like they can guide
them in their way but like I think
trying to change someone that's so young
it's just like backwards like they need
to find their own way in life they need
to find who they are and I don't think
it should depend on somebody else to
find that way in life like I don't think
they should like like I don't know it's
just like they're so young and
impressionable like a year ago they were
17 like and you wouldn't date a 17 year
old so I don't know I just think back to
when I was 18 and I don't think I was
that crazy different than the way I am
now
I don't know I just think like in
general I mean 18 is a bit young for
like I I don't know if I would push like
18 year olds to get married but
um
I don't know I just think like as women
you kind of avoid a lot of like
heartbreak and Trauma if you get married
earlier like I have a friend that got
married at like 21 22 and she's probably
the happiest like person how does she
know uh 27 28. Oh that's not yeah or
don't or don't get married
um
I I was just waiting patiently because
obviously I'm listening to the guys
behind me there's a lot of things I
think you can see from my face that are
actually winding me up and I thought am
I going to take a break here or just be
polite and sit quietly because you
talked about
uh women I think the word used was
combat combative combative yeah they
were yeah that was I was sitting here
and that was winding me up constantly it
the way that you and others were talking
about older women or we're gonna be vice
versa and older men and I was just
getting more and more angry and I
thought well just sit quietly and see
what you've all got to say and we all
have personal opinions
but it doesn't mean that just because
you're with an older woman
that
um they are taking advantage of you and
you're just having fun how about
consider that somebody a little bit
older than you might actually be
interested in you it's not always for
fun I mean you can ask that to me
personally if I'm in getting involved
with someone
I'm not interested in fun you know I've
got personal views self-respect I don't
need to go around dropping my pants like
all these other girls I don't need to do
all that so it doesn't matter who I date
I'm interested in something
proper I think the word is proper
something proper and not to play around
so obviously I'm not going to date you
sort of sorry yeah I just I think that's
just how guys view it like Yeah and I
don't mean any offense personally I just
think when guys typically if they date
girls that are significantly older than
them like long-term guys look at family
and they prefer to have kids of their
own and I just think over a certain age
you're kind of out of the equation no no
I totally understand that and um you
also have to take into account that a
lot of
a lot of men and women already have
children when you meet them and if you
have a good heart and you're a good
person
um you will actually embrace that and I
will be really open about that and I
will say that to anyone I meet if I meet
a man now I don't care how old you are
you know you could be a single dad
whether you're 25 45 and bringing these
kids up on your own I'm going to embrace
that
uh if I got to touch on that I like yeah
like that's I I think it's very like
correct me from I think it's very easy
for like a woman to say that but I just
feel like me I I I'm losing a lot if
I'm dating an older woman who already
has kids like that's baggage I do not
want to carry it's not baggage that's
the word that I didn't like you using
it's it's not baggage you're using
really
nothing but that's that's how men view
it and it's not it's that fun it's not
nice but it's just true all the time not
all men not women men could have baggage
too I would I would not call anything
you have baggage so I'm talking to the
guys behind me so say
um you're 20. say if right now
as a 20 year old you'd already got two
or three kids it's just how it is I
would not even though you're young and
you've had kids at an early age I would
not call that baggage why would you call
kids and life experiences baggage it's
wrong that's a woman's point of view
yeah typically because
more typically because because it
fulfills our meeting strategy because in
history like if a guy could impregnate
multiple people it showed he could take
care of them where men wanted to ensure
paternity and pass on resources to the
kids that are there so like I'm not
saying every single person and every
single guy but it's just how in general
they view it yeah
oh I was just gonna say I think we're
throwing around the word baggage too
Loosely like yeah how how is like
somebody's past experiences and their
children that they've like had from
those past experiences how is that
baggage like because if you're dating
older women you that's the probability
that they have a past marriage and they
have past children so if you don't want
to deal with that baggage then don't
date them and you know what's great but
he's saying he doesn't because that's
baggage to him and I think he should be
allowed to say that yeah you can say
that and remember men have baggage too
let me tell you the baggage you always
like you always you always do this
whenever we say something about women we
always have to say something we do
because we don't why we have to be fair
because the man though all that they get
there's two things
we talk about men's baggage all the time
that we talk about because I don't
really hear them what are you talking
about I'm not in the media all the time
why is men are trash why is that a
common that's not baggage that's that's
a judgment the baggage that men carry if
the older they get as well means they
either been in sales for longer or
they've [ __ ] around for longer so
those two bring two problems either
you're going to be insecure and think
that you cannot trust any woman because
you've been with too many three or fours
or you're going to be very insecure in
yourself and in your manhood because
you've not had enough experience so men
have the insecurities and they have
their baggage that's why you'd rather be
with somebody that's somewhere on your
level because it's easier for both of
you to carry this thing
I I agree with you like what yeah
they're you agree with me yeah some men
have baggage some women have baggage but
I'm saying men and what like like men
and women don't look at children the
same and you can't change reality it
just is what it is yeah like like um
I've heard guys say they get more girls
after they have kids I've never heard a
single mother say her her dating options
got better after a child I've never
heard that like I heard I've heard guys
say they brought their kid to the park
because they know the girls would like
you know oh
men don't want to have to spread their
resources to kids and it's also like
they have a lot of risk that comes with
that like they have to invest in a kid
that's not theirs and I I don't know if
you have kids and I don't know you know
how old the kids are but especially if
they're young they could raise a kid for
10 years and have no legal rights to
that child at the end of it they've got
options if they want to be involved in
the child's life obviously it's a man's
choice if they want to be that involved
and have rights they they can legally
adopt and give their names that child or
they are just the woman's partner who
has kids in their life right and they
can and I think I think if more women
would do that that would help but but I
don't think that's typical with a lot of
single mothers
that's not that's not what I've gathered
because because you asked them like can
can the dad discipline the kid as as his
own so if you disagree with like he
spanks your kid you disagree with it
would you let him do it and a lot of
single mothers say no to that question
but there are a lot more single mothers
and single dads so um right because the
court system doesn't allow a lot of men
to see their children I mean women win
custody 90 of the time and um there's a
lot of guys that get screwed in court
and don't get access leave kids a lot
more I think
can I just interject in that one
um
oh see there's statistics on that but
there's also
there's a big community of men that
don't have access to their children and
they're not being recognized right and
there's a thing where you hear this a
lot you hear this a lot but it's like
there are there are stories of children
that were led to believe by their
mothers that their father left them and
they're somehow at the blue I have a
personal friend of mine for example who
was able to
regain contact with his father after
like 25 years or something or 10 or 15
years sorry minus his childhood
via my LinkedIn and then found out that
it was actually his mother
that pushed him away but he was
indoctrinated with the belief that he
was abandoned by his father so it's just
like whenever I had these these kind of
things I'm not necessarily saying that
not not all men are amazing fathers and
stuff but there's a lot of men out here
that don't have a voice and auto focus
is on the women's side of things
particular things particularly single
files because I have personal experience
of co-parenting right and
I'm not not I try not to like make too
much of a comparison between men and
women but from personal experience
women have many advantages that single
fathers would dream of having
something as basic as picking up your
child from nursery and having to be
interrogated because you're seen as a
threat because you're around it with
children
every single day for the next 15 15
years all these kind of things all add
up so I'm just saying that there's
there's more to it than that than just
like
yeah and I agree with you should accept
because um incarceration like mass
incarceration in America is mainly men
so a lot more women are forced to be
single mothers
yeah so I agree with you yeah I'm just
saying from society most men in the room
right yeah
when you go into a place that has lots
of little children what do you do like
what's your first response I'm
distancing myself as much as possible
I'm saying yeah and then can you imagine
being that child that man with a child
it's it's like it's a really really
challenging dialogue portrayed as like
Predators wear more often that it would
be kind of scary because you don't want
to be seen like that like you like you
want to be like loving but you also feel
restricted by how Society views you no
yeah and and I'd like to say too in the
view in the U.S up there the women
our incentivize to take away the kids
from the dad no because they're paid
more um if the dad doesn't see the kids
they're given more money from Child
Support so they're literally paid to
take away the kids from the dad
um
well I agree with that I just have to
say ladies if you're doing that that's
terrible because having a man that is
willing to be in your child's life is a
blessing if he's willing to do the right
work if you're if you're sleeping you're
sleeping and that's your fault as much
as I Champion my sisters and I always
want to protect women I do know that
when it comes to the relationship
between parent and child that's
something that you really shouldn't play
with and you shouldn't use that to your
advantage or to full power or for
financial gain for whatever it is you're
going to hell for that because it's your
child yeah I'm taking off that point
that's why I wouldn't date a really
older guy because if he had kids or if I
wanted to have kids when I was like when
I was my age they wouldn't be there for
me they couldn't be a father figure
because they would die a lot earlier
than I would and then I would be left
with the responsibilities that's
actually what my dad says with dating
older guys he says my dad says you
should date someone younger as a girl
which is like the opposite of red pill
because he says women live longer yeah
my dad's like a logical guy it's just
Logistics
um yeah
at least that we would die the same age
roughly yeah yeah
I don't know I didn't think that far
um let's do the actual Mia Khalifa video
I found the actual one I wanted to show
you guys
I hope I hope to God this is it you
gotta start it from the beginning
blessing
oh okay well
any guy
who goes after a girl significantly
younger than them is severely lacking in
their life and I I mean that confidence
wise I mean like they are falling short
in so many places that that is the only
place they can turn to to feel like they
have they have something on the scale of
power and it's I mean ultimately it's
predatory I mean there's just no way to
kind of because you're manipulating
someone who does is not aware of what
they're giving you and it's unfair
so my question is why are men called
Predators for going for younger women
but women don't typically have that same
energy for women that go for younger men
I don't know exciting older women also
Prejudice honestly like if you're dating
someone that much younger they have way
less life experience they don't know
themselves as well like you know how to
like shape them like you know to get
them way easier what would you put at
Predator like what what's your what's
the age Gap that you would say Predator
is Kruger
it's a lesson negative word I don't know
maybe
15 20 years 15 20 years and would you
say the age Gap um does it matter how
old the younger person is like if
they're 30 yes yes it does matter if
that if I think if they're under like 25
or if they're under 25 or like under 27
maybe yeah okay and then it's like 20
years yeah Prejudice is the wrong word
Predator is yeah
Predator is the wrong word and should
never be used Predator is the word you
use when you're going after
yeah miners you are yeah you're you know
it isn't being predated as someone that
has kind of power over you no no no a
predator is someone who is seeking out
to do harm so where they're where there
are adults who seek to do harm in a
certain way which I'll you know we can't
say on here to children that is what is
called a predator a predator is not what
was described in that video if you were
a man of any age whether you were going
after a male or female child intending
to meet them to do what you're going to
do that is a predator so on that video
Predator is the wrong word and it's
taken out of context and it of course
it's going to blow up on social media
and people are going to start people are
influenced by people like her and you're
going to start every time you see some a
couple out on the street or in a bar
you're going to turn around oh he's a
predator or she's a predator because
you've heard it on social media it's the
wrong word if you want to know how what
a predator is
yeah it's definitely not that I don't
know if you're underage it's not
consensual if it's between two
consensual adults
must have a bit more intention than that
but I think she's saying I don't know I
don't know what you're saying because
I'm just thinking over the case like
you're you're 18 you have the same
rights that I do if you want to jump in
a car right now you can go do it if you
want to vote you can vote like we're
both adults you know I mean if if we're
talking about under 16 and all them type
of things then we can talk about a
different story but I I think it's uh
like like
um miss lady in front said you know I
think Predator is using the wrong sensor
I think we I'm sorry but my real my real
question is I I don't see the same
energy for women yeah I mean even even
when you started they're like okay but
it's like on social media if a man says
I I like a girl that's significantly
younger he's shamed for it but women
aren't I agree yeah
um it is a bit I'm not gonna lie though
I think that in a girl's world if you're
dating a guy that is younger than you
you are a sometimes can be looked as a
bit weird like why are you going for
like those younger the news why not no
I'm just saying that's how it is usually
in the girls world and I think that the
difference stems from the intentions as
well usually I would say correct me if
I'm wrong I think generally a man that
goes for woman that is younger it'll be
for those reasons of like okay she's
less combative she's
um you know easier to mold and all these
things fine is that right wait whereas
if you're a woman and you're going for a
younger guy a lot of the time I feel it
might be for the energy
now they've got a whole woman so I think
like I think that the intentions may be
slightly different and that's why I mean
what they're getting at and I think
they're probably talking from experience
you can tell the look in their eyes when
you're when you're a young woman
especially if you're a pretty young
woman a lot of older men will approach
you and at that moment in time when
you're that age there's a lot of things
that you really just don't know in fact
you don't even know enough about men to
be able to navigate the world with these
sort of men after you so that's why they
would come or say use such a strong word
to describe it because actually at the
end of the day it is a little bit
twisted what about a girl that what is
it
but why don't we have that same energy
of young women that go after older men
for their money
predator
would you say that Leonardo DiCaprio I
would argue yeah
that you have Leonardo DiCaprio dating
27 years old is crazy
man so it's wrong for
let's say it's wrong for men in their
30s to go for 18 year olds I understand
why they would like the the submissive
being cooperative and like less bodies
but why would an older woman in their
like 30s go for a guy who is like 20
like what benefits what benefits do you
get from going from
just just a stamina that's it do you not
want like I'm the girls that actually go
for younger men I do not want a man that
can provide and be like a proper leader
I know there are some younger guys but
generally speaking men men under 30 they
can't really give you what you want so I
just want to know what I would say they
love you way harder if they're younger
because you're more likely to be there
one of their first loves you know I mean
like I think as they are older the love
gets a little bit more like I've done
this a thousand times like well and it's
kind of I mean it's kind of a meeting
strategy in a way because it's like men
have less actual Capital when they're
younger and then women have less sexual
Capital when they're older so they kind
of hit off each other yeah and don't
forget also what the boy said earlier
they're like oh yeah she was so much
more mature and she was this and yeah I
enjoyed it and this so they appreciated
her and I said so it's nice yeah but
what's the what's the woman gaining I
get them what the man you get validated
yeah we like nice words we just want a
man to appreciate us
um long that's why don't forget that
women also went and they require a lot
of validation so sometimes when you go
for younger Monday he's able to give you
that but all these guys have just said
that they're only looking to like not
really like a long commitment with an
older woman because she has like too
much baggage and all of that so like
what is the older women getting out of
this if it's not just fine like if it's
if she's looking for a long time
commitment like what is she finding with
these young men that don't want a long
time coming with an older woman yeah
would you say it's more companionship
yeah because so I'm gonna ask you
because you actually date younger man
um yeah it's companionship and I won't
judge a young man my I've said it
already earlier on my ex was a lot
younger than me and age was totally
irrelevant
um you there are some gaps there are
things that he won't know and I won't
know and then somewhere you sort of just
meet in the middle but you get
companionship you you know I I was in
love we were I could say we were
genuinely in love you know I'm not going
to talk about the reasons we broke up
but yeah we were together four years and
that was with someone younger than me I
had companionship I had friendship I had
someone that understood me I had love I
had someone that looked out for me he
was actually a great cook
um I'm a bit lazy at that
um you know I used to go over to his
home and there was always food food
waiting for me not because I couldn't
you know go in the kitchen and make
something it was a real relationship so
everyone experiences something different
I think we've just got too many
stereotypes is oh you can't go out with
a younger man or you can't go out with
someone old man so you might tell me oh
I can't go out with someone that's 60 or
70. but what happens you know if I'm
attracted they're a nice man the
relationship is nice they're a good
person to me yeah the companionship is a
big word so to me it doesn't really
matter you have to it's something that
we all said here before you have to and
you said it particularly it it depends
on the actual person so if I'm gonna
have a relationship I mean I don't want
a fling I don't want to be
I would want to be with a man that's
just going to fling his bits around
um to put it politely it doesn't matter
how old you are obviously we all have
age restrictions but if I like you we're
attracted you respect me
you know you have love for me you're my
friend you're my companion you look out
for me you're a man you're a man you're
a leader you know how to look after me
it doesn't really matter if you've got
all those qualities
I'm Gonna Be With You
how no never mind the age some people I
know that men I think mature a little
bit later we will know that but what
happens when there's us individuals who
are the right one for you
I just have a question though like yeah
of course um you know obviously you
think that way now when you was like in
your late
um late 20s or like early 30s did you
think the same way like would you still
look for like a younger guy in that same
companionship role or you is this a
recent thing where you decided no no
nothing nothing is recent My Views have
never changed
um just a man has to be a good man
someone that wants to
look after me but can I just ask would
you seek out a younger man actively
actively actively know but if one
crossed my path and they happen to be
you know let's say I'm just gonna get
thrown number out here if one crossed my
path and all of a sudden I met them and
and they I said how old were you and
they told me let's say for example
between 25 and 30 I'm not all of a
sudden I'm going to turn around and say
I'm sorry I can't date you because of
your age they might be the right person
for me yeah fair enough what about like
an 18 year old like if you were just out
there on an 18 year old account machine
was like oh you're a beautiful woman so
so there's a hard cap too yeah there is
no I wouldn't okay no no it's kind of
interesting because you kind of
contradict yourself yeah no I understand
I understand I understand what you mean
and talk about contradictions so we all
have age limits and we've all talked
about it here tonight and whilst I'm
talking about yes I will date a younger
man I still have my limit so I don't
think that's me contradicting myself I'm
saying yes I'll date a younger man but
I'm capping a limit just like everybody
else so I don't think that I'm I'm being
contradictory
I just wanna
excuse me I just want to add um so
um in terms of my experience with women
yeah
[Music]
I've never actually been in a
relationship with a woman that's younger
than me
and um what I
hearing these discussions for me the two
key words of the two takeaways are you
for maturity I think it goes in both
directions
um so I think for me I I presented
myself
has been a lot more older than I then I
guess in terms like the barometer of
menma age
and that's sort of what a lot of women
responded to and then once I'd
filled my age
in comparison to the the age that they
had the mental image that they had of me
it sort of I don't know just sort of
made something inside them just go a bit
I don't know I'm a bit addicted to me in
a certain way
um
so I just think I think it goes both
ways because you're saying earlier about
the 18 year olds and the 32.
maturity doesn't necessarily have a
fixed age if someone carries themselves
as like a 25 year old or 42 year old and
stuff more often than not weak kind of
like connect with that as opposed to
checking people's ID cards so
um that was just my my takeaway for that
it's all what society and people around
us say is the right thing to do it's
it's it's almost like saying I can't be
your friend unless you eat chalk mint
chocolate
you know everyone has to eat meat mint
chocolate if you want to be connected to
me because that's what Society that's
what the news tell us to do that's what
social media tells us to do that's what
your friends are telling you to do how
about what you want to do and how
sitting down with yourself and thinking
actually is this right does it work is
that the right person for me or am I
only doing what Society
expect me to do have you ever had
someone
um do you typically not tell people your
age when you meet them like guys you're
talking to or interested in
um guys that I'm talking to
um they're dating whatever yeah well I
mean I'm I've been single for a couple
of years by choice because I'm not I'm
not gonna just go out there and date
anyone and just for the sake of it
um once I start talking to someone yeah
we do we do discuss ages and backgrounds
and okay so you you tell them up front
yeah okay I wasn't sure if has anyone
ever um rejected you because of your age
do they know before the date oh oh
always yeah I think the only time you
get rejected is sometimes based on
Color Race religion culture those are
the things when all of a sudden things
change but age no I've never had a
problem with that I have actually been
rejected because of my age so I just
think like age is also equal to like
raise color like same version and stuff
I've met older guys and then they find
out that I'm like at the time while 18
19 20 whatever and they were like Oh no
you're too young so I think it's very
it's just very circumstantial but the
probability when you're younger that
you're not going to match with someone a
bit older than you is more likely like I
think with the mint chocolate idea like
like concept you're you're more likely
to like a mint chocolate that's your own
age you know I mean because you're in
the same stage of life more likely but
obviously there's going to be those
people those outliers that that are that
do match you
have um have any raise your hand out of
the guys has a girl ever told you that
you're too young for her
ever
interesting okay I was just curious
you know I I you had a guy so four out
of five okay when you asking that
question are you talking about now when
we were younger because ever I mean yeah
yeah yeah I don't know I just feel like
yes there's exceptions to the rule like
the minimals the one percent all of
these things that is fantastic ideally
would work fantastically but I the way I
look at a relationship is that your
birth running the same race separately
and then that means that you're more
likely to be successful you're both
running the same race separately yeah
the same way that you say people are the
same but they're different the same
difference that all that kind of thing
because this is like a parallel thing
and you're striving towards the same
goal which would be to raise a family to
obviously have a good relationship
together for the rest of your life
success blah blah blah blah blah and I
think it's much easier and I think it's
more you're more likely to succeed if
you are at similar stages and levels
because there's so much more
understanding in terms of even culture
in terms of social context and
everything so I just think you're more
likely to be more successful in that
with somebody that is closer to you in
so many more areas what do you think the
number one swiped right age is on dating
apps for men and for women if you've
heard this on the show before please
don't ruin it what's the wall what are
you okay what do you think the number
one swipe right so like yes 22 ages for
men and for women both yeah over dating
apps women is probably going to be like
32 no I'll say 20 22 for women no women
um
start here and then go around
um for men I'll probably think 24 25 for
women
um 40.
I think guys would pick like
23 girls 32.
um men men 20 women 30 35 so I think men
are probably gonna pick like
22 23 I think guys are probably gonna go
for like
oh wait wait what am I saying like guys
are going for them
yeah so I think guys we'll be going for
like 25 year olds I think women are
going for like older like 28 29 because
they want the money yeah okay I think
most guys have money by 28 29. good
[Laughter]
um I think men are going for like
probably like 21 maybe even like 2019
and then girls are going for like 26.
okay uh girls are going out to 22 20 no
sorry guys are going for women who are
around 22 23 and I think women are going
for guys that are like 29 30.
I fit men are picking women
that are probably 22 23 and women are
going for guys
32 to 35.
me I think uh the men will go after the
girls who are
20 21 and then the girls are probably
going like 32 to be fair
yeah I'd say most swept women 22 most
swapped guys three
no one got it
what is it
I was actually really I didn't believe
this when I first saw it I I was shocked
and I'm I'm me you know
um the most swiped right age for a guy
um Did anyone say 40s anyone it's
actually older it's actually older than
that it's 50. wow
this was like uh plenty this is
I don't know if it was plenty I could
look it up I don't know the exact app
someone someone put in the comments all
right most swiped right for girls
18. oh God
so all these guys want 18 year olds
I mean I would say I would say the most
desired
um
women are gold diggers
you know I've got a big bum right no you
just said you just sat right on me
should I address the elephant in the
room
take your hood off stop hiding no I'm
not hiding yeah you are should I dress
the elephant in the room Pole oh
let it out quickly
do you see the elephant in a room
at 10 000 lakhs ten thousand lakhs we'll
address that see that late I love the
show though it's amazing
okay adios
I wonder what the elephant in the room
is I think well
curious I hope it's nothing to do with
me
I thought it was like last time okay
um okay back to the decision
what were we even talking about okay
1850.
where he was he was saying
um people are swiping 18 year old girls
yeah I mean I think it's a typical I
mean why are models typically young like
men tend to like younger women women
tend to like older men women are
attracted to God that can protect and
provide um a man hits his financial
stride and it's like 40s or 50s men men
tend to be attracted to fertility in
youth I don't think most guys like want
to date an 18 year old super like I
don't I don't talk to a lot of guys in
real life that say like their number one
option is 18 like it seems to be more
like 22 to 28 seems to be what guys I
talk to typically say but
um yeah I mean typically men go for
fertility in youth that's why they call
it Forever 21 not forever 50s
I think as as Society becomes more
perpetuated on how people look younger
girls aren't going for us old guys
because I know in myself like I wouldn't
give someone super old because I
couldn't take your pictures with them
like I I couldn't be as proud of them
and I think societies coming feminized
in that aspect
um yeah I mean that's what it's funny I
was really surprised by this I swear to
God when I saw this data I I was shocked
I I couldn't believe it because I was
like I don't know many girls that want
to date 50 year olds but that's what
they're swiping on them but you know
it's on Tinder then we have to consider
that sorry just to be a sugar baby it's
either match or Plenty of Fish but
either way
because Plenty of Fish
so you've got barefooters that's crazy
but it's because of the way people are
using dating Labs people don't actually
use datey apps to get married okay so
that's that's what you would think right
but that's actually it's actually the
number one way people meet today
that's the number one so so ladies and
gentlemen that's why we have issues
no you're you're you're right you're
right but I'm saying like that's if
that's the number one way long-term
relation chips are forming nowadays and
that's what men and women are swiping on
that says something
and some some apps are a little
different but they're only different by
like a a couple years it's really not
that different is it like dating apps
are kind of like corn they over
exaggerate the reality of things you I
when you're going on on dating apps you
can actually be in touch with an 18 year
old where in reality if you're a 50 year
old man hanging around 18 year old
you're a weirdo so that's okay if you're
if you're hot you're hot like hot girls
get swiped say like it it doesn't at one
age it doesn't matter but but the point
is in general men tend to like younger
women and in general women tend to like
older men but the exaggeration of the 18
is just an example it's just showing it
it's not very good and that's what
people are seeing and they're looking
out and it's not very good it's not a
very good example to send it's not
actually something great it's not bad
because why is it not because
these stats are things that there's
they're part of what I would say a
certain fantasy and idealization of what
people think dating is and you and then
they almost become a reality and it
stops it but it is is what it is you
can't no I'm saying you're painting if
if we ask the married people how did you
meet your spouse and they say dating
apps and then we go to the dating apps
and say okay what ages are people
swiping on I have to agree how is that
delivered in reality no that that what
that is doing is just showing how
twisted it is so basically there's a lot
of men that go in looking for young
girls online 18 not even 22 or 23 18
blood but I think whatever
why does that matter
it does matter it does matter because
it's the same thing that I keep saying
like is this fantasy this fantasization
okay guys so if you if you've taken
anything from this conversation guys
don't really care about age like the
number that just are you hot are you not
but young girls
like I think what you're trying to
emphasize is that like that for women
there's a lot more of an idolization for
youth like when it's with man it's not
as attached like as as women get older a
lot of people think oh they're not as
smart they're not as their advice isn't
as helpful but when men get older
they're more wise they're more helpful
like like you always hear the wise man
story you don't hear the wise woman
story do you yeah okay so basically they
don't like wrinkles yeah in a way
because it displays that you're not as
fertile in and and I think that's what
Paul would say but that's an average
woman knows that herself because I mean
it's just clear that you guys obviously
put so much more attention money into
your parents we spent we spent 300 000
more in a Lifetime on beauty products
and I mean like why why do we get why do
we get lip filler why do we get BOTOX
why do we get all of this stuff to look
younger
women get better men that pay for a
nicer lifestyle so yeah yeah also are
these guys even looking at the age
because they could just be seeing young
good looking swipe right you know I
wanted to say that like dudes are just
like that guys
I mean we all know those people that
peaked in high school and like and you
know now they look like a mini whale or
a Lego whale like you know
so but I just want to be clear so like
this you keep on saying go the younger a
girl is the hotter she is so it's like I
genuinely don't think in hotness there's
a massive like I actually think girls in
their 20s like mid like just early 20s
mid 20s late 20s they look better than
18 year olds they know they have money
they know how to do their makeup they
don't have to like this idea 18 year
olds yeah 18 year olds look better than
any girl in it I think that's yeah the
date in that profile picture will just
be like a boohoo dress or something so
yeah
if you're a date and 18 year old that
doesn't look great you can just
influence her to dress how you think
it's better I mean they they say it's
like 18 to 28 is like when a woman's
sexual peak is like these are her best
years and and it's kind of it's it seems
to be kind of similar with the answers
to the guy that the guys gave right
um they I mean according to this this
date like it depends who you ask
this said 50 was the number one age
swiped right on um anecdotally I would
guess mid-30s early 40s I would say
because then I mean because you have all
the girls that are younger than you you
take a bigger pool I'd imagine but I I
feel like the um the data skewed though
in the sense though
um
from personal experience
the younger you go the more options you
have as in people actually using these
dating apps
um so there's probably like a smaller
pool of like people probably above 25
Fey you are looking for science areas
and there's a lot more like you know
you've got your computer and people in
universities so there's like a if
there's going to be like I don't know
40 of the total 100 in University then
chances are the 18 year old kind of that
makes more sense yeah you are right yeah
I'm saying in terms of people going for
that because
um I use I think hinge like a couple
months ago and I set my preference
um I think my lower end was like 23 and
you ran out of options but then when you
drop it down to 22 all of a sudden it's
just flooded I mean so I think there's
also some sort of skewing in terms of
that statistics because all domain here
for me it's just generally like 20 at
the A's that I'm at I know that nearly
every man that I know is gonna 22 23 22
is a bit too young but that 23 is like
the ideal age
um and then the older you get I guess it
just kind of
stays around there and then goes up a
bit completely like I don't know like
more people that are young use dating
apps like more 18 to 21 year olds use
dating apps more than you would say like
a 28 to 32 year old because they're
looking for like people roughly that age
and I don't know people that younger use
the internet more often and stuff like
you don't get like many 40 year olds
like on dating apps I don't think
personally just for my personal
experience yeah so how about does the
data basically exactly how accurate is
it it doesn't show like a complete like
representation of all the different ages
I just think the point is that men tend
to like younger women and women tend to
like older men even if the data is a bit
off by like five years like let's give
it five ten years it's still it's still
the general conclusion is still going to
be the same to be with 18 and 50. I'm
not gonna lie I kind of let me tell you
the truth that I must admit I agree with
you now pal
I always said that I want my man to be
older than me even if it's by one year
because that one year alone will be able
to give this nice room where I can give
him another sort of respect above me
because submission for me is difficult
to have the meat that helps not because
I want his money but because it will
allow me to actually give him the
respect that he is looking for as a man
naturally without having to like fake it
women tend to like um a guy is five to
seven years older than them
and then there's another study which was
closer to 22 where they asked men like
when they found women the most
attractive between the ages of like 18
and like 70 and they all said 22. so
it's it's you know different studies
will give it but it's it's generally for
women between 18 and 25 roughly
good to be an exception to the rule yeah
can I ask a question like um uh actually
it's more directed to my man at back I'm
sorry I forgot your name oh just Joshua
Josh yeah
um just on this whole the baggage thing
like you were like uh when they're older
this package you don't want to deal with
that and it's kind of like and you were
like she's got issues she's got life
experiences and whatnot and it's just
from the perspective of like let's
accept issues or Quake baggage
um like most of people's issues come
from like in their younger years like
their relationship with their parents
like abuse that happens with like
extreme cases abuse when they're like
younger children like just so you can
get I suppose my point is
you're here you look for a younger girl
because she's I suppose more of a clean
slate but what happens when you get like
a younger guy and she's like gone
through that sort of stuff or like has
mental health problems or do you go I
mean no definitely definitely and what I
would say to that is to think of it like
this let's say even if the case that
they do experience that at a younger age
the more time I give them
they're going to still be in the dating
pool they're still gonna have other
experiences added on top of that so I
think of more I think it more of like
let me catch it at the shortest point
you know what I mean because sure you
could go through all those different
dramas whatever whatever but then I
could be that cutting point for you you
know what I mean instead of you going
into five other different relationships
to 30 other different bodies okay maybe
that's extreme but it's like
the more time I give you the more that's
going to be added on to that so it's
like let me just cut it while it's short
you know you feel me yeah yeah it's not
the same for men then as well
um because men will get more buyers the
longer they live
I don't really think you you like
originally I don't think you guys really
care about that in the sense like
because I think we have to we have
different type of baggage women love
baggage actually I don't want them out
with kids that's what you would think
but but that's not true according to the
day you know felons um violent felons
reproduce more than non non-violent
felons
can I just ask a question here
um correct me I feel like when the guys
are talking about baggage and then when
the women are talking about baggage I
feel like the word the definition of
that word is slightly different
two different things so yeah when you're
saying bags I feel like I understand you
but when you you're saying baggage I
feel like something else you're talking
about something else I'm seeing kids I'm
saying a lot of past relationships I'm
saying trauma that I could step on
accidentally things like that is that
the same for the rest of you I consider
that kind of baggage maybe yeah I I
don't think I don't personally think
that men with kids is baggage but I
think women with kids are baggage for
men because you guys gotta provide for
the kid yeah after the kid and
everything I just don't think if a man's
in a certain position that you want him
to be in if he's got a kid then I don't
see that as a baggage but you're gonna
have to be a mother to someone else's
thing like yoga how is that not a baby
or a baby mama drama yeah I'm constantly
seeing a child that reminds you of their
ex yes
as a jealous lady thank you
I'm not saying it's the same type of
baggage but it is it is like a
responsibility that
it's not like ideal but I just think
um it's less important than like it's
worth for you guys to meet a woman that
has kids than for me to meet a man that
has kids I think
um
the mum usually looks after the kid
anyway in most cases more than the dad
you don't have to actually be a stepmom
I don't think okay wait so just so I I
just I don't want to misunderstand you
so you're saying for a man going for a
woman who has kids
it's more it's it's all baggage but it's
more of a baggage for a man entering
that situation it's more of a burden for
a man that's what I think the financial
investment information if if dads are
less involved and being a stepdad you
basically don't have to do because men
are less involved in the parenting if
you're saying that women naturally yeah
because you said that women are what
she's talking about I think you're
talking about primary custody right no
but like you said the women are more
like to take off to the kids but then if
you're a stepdad you're not going to
really have to be around like you'll be
around them but you won't have too much
of a dad to them so like if you had a
kid and he was your your man that he
wouldn't yeah
if we like live together I guess
it's just um the biggest issue that I've
I've heard um like my co-host on
Tuesdays is named Sarah he said that he
had he dated um a single mom for 10
years was basically that a lot of single
mothers will let you know that you're
not the dad
and so basically like if you want to
parent them one way and she wants to
parent them a different way it like
she'll always let you know that's not
your kid
I said they lose the dominance kind of
they lose that it's just I mean they
have all the responsibility of the kid
they have to make sure he's fed they
have to make sure he's taken care of
they have to make sure you know he has a
male role model all that stuff but they
they don't get I mean yeah the
responsibility that comes with it
but then you've got baby father drama as
well and baby fathers when it comes to
stepping on another man's ego oh they
never like okay it's I personally like I
I think it would be wait okay I think I
think it would be hard to date a guy
with kids personally but I just don't
tell the world what to be and women tend
to go for men with kids more than
without kids like again historically it
was a sign of pre-selection like how did
gangas Khan impregnate like half of the
world like
you know
I I I I I agree with that one to an
extent to be fair I think it's just when
you have people that have that kind of
lifelong commitment with somebody else
because that's what happens when you
have a child I think on both sides it
brings a lot of complications I think
that's right you don't want that drama
I'm curious who here um raise your hand
if you would date someone with a kid
okay so one two three okay I have in the
past but it's not my preference it's not
your preference yeah exactly I would but
it wouldn't be my preference but as as
women well me anyway I will I would go
for a man who is around his 30s he's
more likely to have a child like it
wouldn't be my first pick but you know
if he's got all the other qualities and
stuff rather than
someone who doesn't have the qualities I
want and doesn't have a kid then
yeah I feel like it's easier to
emotionally invest and be maternal to
someone else's kids than for a man to
financially invest in someone else's
kids so you're saying it's like easier
for a woman in that sense yeah
I don't know
I think that
if you're a man and you're doing your
thing money ain't nothing but a thing
that's it yeah
it's not the case but it that's the
thing you really still shouldn't be
there but it's not even about money a
lot of the time it's again back to the
freedom without responsibility so they
have all the responsibility of a kid but
they don't get the freedom the freedom
to parent them how they want and then on
top of that like you know she can leave
and then he'll have no rights to the
kids well yeah and that lack of Freedom
like will um kind of be reciprocating
your relationship I guess because she's
got power over something you don't but
what all of the guys have been saying is
that like they don't want to look after
somebody else's kid because it's a
burden to them they have to provide for
these kids so it is about the money then
isn't it they don't want to perform this
kid and give emotional money and money
like
um financial support to this kid you
just said it wasn't about the money you
said it was about no I'm I'm saying
sorry if I said it wasn't about the
money at all I misspoke I I'm just
saying it's not always just about the
money so even if a guide has money he
still
he's like he still has the issue that
she will remind you that it's not your
kid moms but something without the
factor of the money if if they know that
you have a kid and they're still looking
for a long-term situation then why does
the kid matter like if you know they
have a kid and you still want a
long-term situation with them then if
you're not willing to put in the effort
and like that risk take that risk that
if it does end then the kid will be out
of your life then why are you still
going into it I think I think It
ultimately depends on the baby father
like how involved he is in in all of
this because between men there's there's
like an on on unspoken codes
if if that if if yes if he's completely
out of the picture then you have a lot
more options as a man to to to do what
you've got to do
but if you have to interact with this
guy every every Friday when he comes to
pick up the kids you know what I mean
and you look at each other you size each
other up and then he's just there it's a
lot more aggro in a hassle you don't
need it it's dangerous it's dangerous
for men because if he if he's just come
out of a 10-year stretch and you know I
mean all these kind of things as a man
you like just just a woman with another
child puts You In Harm's Way as a man
because you don't know who this guy who
she she breeded with you know I mean I
would never date someone with a kid
because I don't want to deal with their
like their emotional baggage and like
kind of be responsible for their past
decisions because that is like you
having a child was a decision and now I
have to be responsible for that decision
and it's like it's not I shouldn't have
to take that all off you like I don't
have to deal with your past traumas
because they're yours they're not mine
yeah because I was saying just adding on
to it so I'm not gonna go into like
names and stuff but like
um as Paul was saying about you know the
authority
especially from like a masculine
perspective
already taken on someone else's
child if you look at it from like a
survival perspective that child
effectively is your enemy which is why
when Lions take over Pride they make
sure to to kill off any legacies that
was there before and they start again
but then to to swallow that pride is one
thing but then if you you you as of like
in in the traditional sense you need to
kind of like run your house
but then if there's children here
yeah it's like if you respect the mother
her her not allowing you the authority
over that child those children are on
the same level as her so it's just like
that whole like the whole respect tree
someone in the chat said it's like
paying for another man's orgasm exactly
you said that they're fully developed by
three and if you meet her and she's got
a five-year-old that kid knows you're
not their their dad like they're gonna
it depends I mean it depends how it runs
out the domain the main thing yeah the
main film I'm trying to get across right
is the fact that like all of these
things yeah it just is very case
specific but generally speaking
from a male perspective there's just so
many factors that you have to swallow
and ignore and just try and ride with it
reminded they have slept with someone
every day seeing that kid like it's not
speaking from experience like I've got
my parents split when I was very young
and yeah and my mum got had a new man
from early so I grew up with another man
in the household and I didn't like him
at all like we constantly clashed heads
I was very much like always on my dead
side I was always looking at it like
why are you with him and not my dad
sorry for him it must have been horrible
yeah even in a household where you know
that this kid doesn't like you but if
they can if they can get over that
insecurity of the fact that there's
another man that like like fathered that
their their girlfriend or wife say child
then like I just don't see what the
problem is like what you were saying
about like how they have to like see
this other man if he's still in like the
picture and it's not easy to get it just
sounds like it's like that stems from
their insecurity like if you're too
insecure about the fact that the goal
you're seeing has had another like baby
in the past then like don't see her like
why is that her why is like you making
like her issue that is your problem yeah
it's like you're meeting someone's ex
every Friday like meeting their ex like
if you don't like anything isn't it I
just understand it if you don't like it
don't get into the relationship
yeah but we're just explaining like why
men don't yeah
I'll agree with that even further
actually because my mum was alone for a
very long time because my dad passed
away when we were 12. and I remember
when I was 15 14 15 even 16 any man that
ever got close to my mom oh the four of
us because we're four girls we used to
give him hell because we had a certain
possession over our mom and with kids we
didn't know a lot of the time we were
younger we had a possession of our mum
and we also have loyalty to our dad yeah
okay and okay fine fair enough yeah my
dad passed away and there's a difference
but actually I find that to be the case
with a lot of people especially if the
children have got a good relationship
with the father it feels like a betrayal
yeah it's a betrayal so I think that
when you bring that kind of situation to
your life you have to understand that
there's so many elements now that you've
added to your life they have absolutely
no control over absolutely no control it
can be absolutely chaos or you can go
well a lot of the time it may not go
well in the society that we live in now
I would say if you're like maybe in
Africa you know in other continents
where life is a bit more difficult than
you actually have a bit more generous
through struggle maybe but even still I
would just say keep it clean keep it
simple keep it straight and easy it's
such a complex situation to walk into so
like generally speaking men will just be
like you know what if I got the choice
to go for a woman without kids no woman
with kids
yeah because I think just just to just
to add on to what you're saying like
generally speaking Journey speaking most
children kind of have like a maternal
yearning so like if you're like say your
your father were just children you could
have sisters aunties mothers and stuff
they sort of like represent the body of
a mother in a way but then with the
father side of things you kind of have
need that sort of like one reference
point
generally speaking but then if if you
are given the authority over the child
to raise that child as your own as a man
then that child's father has effectively
lost his child that creates a new
Dynamic that just within the male
Spectrum it's just so many moving pieces
I think for afraid to work for it to
work the biological data would have to
be completely out of the situation
completely yeah it's not inclined and
accept you calling his child Dad yeah
and because I've seen it with a friend
like that she
um you know he he had a situation and
his baby mother or the mother of his
child had a new guy it was very
traditional he's like this is my house
all the children call me that
it's also
um women tend to leave relationships
more than men so it's like Why didn't it
work out with the baby father women
leave 70 to 80 percent of the time 90 of
their college educated if she left the
father of her kids she might leave you
too men value loyalty uh-uh listen we we
can't use the stats to say much because
if we break those tests down for reasons
why and you look at the pairings and you
know how the number one reason is
financial okay so let me tell you
something about finances yeah
as a man if you're meant to be a
provider if you are with a woman that
earns more than you she may leave you
but it's not always because she's gas
and she thinks she's better than you a
lot of the time when you are more likely
to leave after a promotion yeah but wait
like a lot of the time when you are
doing more than your man is in the field
that he's supposed to be doing more than
you are because he's going to then act
out against you not because you he how
do you know they're not acting out
against him and acting like they're
better than him because he can go both
ways okay and that's why when we use
these stats we need to look at the
reasonings why because a lot of the time
men get really upset because their woman
is doing better than him and that makes
him feel emasculated to leave your
husband because he's upset no because if
he if he treats me like crap because I'm
making it because deep down he knows I'm
making more money he's making him feel
some type of way and he's not making me
happy of course I'm gonna have to leave
I'm not gonna like quit my job so that
you can feel better about yourself about
the kids happiness and not yours the
case happen is dependent also my
happiness but why because if I'm because
I think happiness is a choice
um it is a choice and that's why you
make the right choices if it's a choice
then why can't you be happy
well I can't be happy but if there is
somebody in my life that is he who's
happy unhappiness is affecting mine
because energies are contagious then I
have to separate myself especially even
for kids this is the thing sometimes we
think that for children the best thing
is for parents to be together no I mean
the best because statistically well the
best thing the best thing for kids when
when
um when they are young growing up is to
have a healthy loving relationship being
shown in front of them if you two are
not getting on as a married couple at
least separate but keep the love for the
child because at the end of the day it's
not about you and the person being
together about that kid growing up
healthy with mental and emotional
stability turning along why can't you
just live in separate rooms
live in separate houses why because
living in separate rooms well I want
it's better for the kids to have two
parents in the home you know what I
genuinely but see this is like a modern
mindset where it's like me me me first
my happiness first before my own
children and like that I think that's
why we have like a very [ __ ] up
society today because it's me me my
happiness me because your happiness
directly affects somebody if I'm
depressed my child like okay if if I'm
in a terrible relationship it's like
okay you can just figure out how to get
along with people but what I think it's
so important right if if we look at them
and put things aside that you're
compromising your values
you take in front of God I would say all
Society very much is about individualism
now because like capitalism is
fundamentally based on individualism and
so therefore you you feed into your own
values now so now when you're in a
marriage you think what do I want not
what my husband or partner wants right
that's the problematic because it makes
it more competitive the market and it
makes your day I think it's a problem
because it's not supposed to be about
you it's supposed to be about the family
exactly supposed to be especially the
kid like I just think as a mother you
should want your kids to be happy Above
All Else But if you're sadden your
relationship surely that's gonna
transpire on your kids I know but I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying like why
can't you just put that aside but let's
say raise your kid raise your kids and
then after that you could focus on your
happiness
is that as a child you learn by example
and if you watch your parents argue or
you watch your mum constantly compromise
her values and say fine learn not to
argue yeah but the fact you're not to
get learn to get along but what if
you're like I don't want to do that and
you always see your mum being like I
don't want to do that in your and your
father is forcing her to do that you
learn growing up that you're that what
you want doesn't matter and you just
have to force yourself to do what you
don't like and that could put you in
really harmful situations don't you
think you're saying to teach these young
girls to be complacent like see their
mothers just speak in placement of the
fact they're unhappy with this man put
the family above you for some I'm not
saying I'm saying I I don't I'm not for
abuse so and completely if it's an
abusive situation that's different yeah
but but I think I think I think I think
wait okay I think happiness comes and
goes
and I think there were a lot of times my
parents have been married 30 years and
there have been a lot of times where my
mom maybe wasn't happy for a couple
years or my dad maybe wasn't happy for a
couple years but because of us they
stuck it out and they got happier and
they learned to work it out and they
learned to get along and I think a lot
of times in our society we we throw in
the towel before we've even really tried
and I think that's the average length of
a first marriage is seven to eight years
in a household rather not be together
like as a couple but in front of the
kids you can just be a united front yeah
but then you can live your own private
lives
but you live together like you see right
I think if you're going into on a
marriage thinking that you're going to
be happy you're going in for the wrong
reasons because just like Pro said
they're going to be situations where
you're not going to be happy just
because you're not happy you're gonna
leave now no if you if you stand before
that Court you stand before you sign the
paper you agreed to death to life to
worse to better and not just because
you're happy you have kids involved
though it's not about your happiness
anymore because the fact that you two
gonna stay there that's gonna that's
gonna greatly impact the child's life so
if we're not talking about no extreme
cases about you know like any um you
know sa going on at home and any abuse
or whatever
you're I don't want to put it so bluntly
but it's not about your happiness your
life is not yours anymore you're raising
kids now that's the center your life so
forget your happiness work it out look
at our grandmas we talk to our great
great day when you think that they're
going to hell right they will see their
man cheating but they say look I got
kids so I gotta put my kids before me
because I know they need me in the house
and I think that's like even if you said
we become way more individualistic now
and is that even to our benefit look at
the results it's not doing us any good
okay so just taking off what you said
and the whole it's about the the family
so your idea of it's about the family is
okay let's just say you're like because
you're talking about a very specific
situation the ups and downs of a
marriage where you can be unhappy happy
happy that's fine and I think most
people would agree on you you need to
ride the highs with the lows but if
you've got a situation where let's just
for the sake of this argument we've got
a woman and her daughter or even like
actually even flip it a man and his son
and that's this dude is habitually
unhappy like every day just unhappy
miserable whole family feels it all the
kids feel it you're like yo but you're
staying there you're putting your family
first but you're teaching this boy this
is what marriage looks like this is what
wait wait this is what a family looks
like so he then goes on to have his own
family where he's habitually unhappy and
then he teaches his son to do so you
have this line of people just unhappy
but married but like this idea of a
family together wait wait wait wait wait
wait let me just let me just something
about happiness it's about Duty
and I understand that but I don't think
like because to me you're like as long
as you are together that's the most
important thing and you stay together
like even if you're unhappy even
basically it is
because you're more likely to run away
from home you're more likely to go to
jail you're more likely to get bad
grades in school every statistical
disadvantage you can put a kid at
they're at when you take the father out
of the home what about yourself and so I
what I'm saying is that it's marriage is
not about happiness it's about Duty okay
and then my best friend everyone's what
Mario best friend have a baby with your
best friend like is your friend with
benefits but you have a child so it's
easier because you respect each other
you love each other and you don't really
need to argue
regardless there there is going to be an
unhappy time and like I said we can't
base a marriage off of happiness because
if if you come into a stinking look I'm
gonna get married with this love of my
life because they treat me well and
they're going to treat me like a queen
you're not gonna be happy for the rest
of my life no because they're gonna be a
day you might go to a financial hardship
you might go to a health situation is
that going to be the breaking point
you're like okay no I'm not happy no I'm
gonna leave no you got kids so you're
responsibility if I had to take why
can't we figure out a solution just tell
them like if you're really unhappy why
can't you figure out a solution maybe
maybe it's maybe it's sleeping in
separate bedrooms for a couple years
till you figure out how to maybe maybe
it's wait sorry maybe it's marriage
counseling maybe it's sleeping in
separate bedrooms for a couple of years
maybe be it's I don't know consoling
with your church family whatever it is
but it's like why why is the first go-to
always divorce divorce divorce I
understand that and I get that in okay
yeah I get that and okay I get that in a
case where you're like you've got two
people and they both like you've at
least got two people and they're willing
to work on it whatever but what if
you've got a situation where you have a
person who is like I want to stay and
let's just say it's fundamentally there
are these things you do that make me
unhappy and that person like I'm not
gonna right so you should carry so you
so what's the answer then like if you've
got this situation where someone is like
I'm doing my thing and I'm living and
I'm not changing so the unhappy person
example of an actual situation okay cool
so to like narrow it down so 100 uh
you've got a man and he's married to a
woman and he fundamentally is like so so
to me the underpinning is this is my
thinking he chose wrong when he married
this woman okay and the reason is he
wants someone who fundamentally is
submissive to him that's what he wants
and when that doesn't when that doesn't
manifest he feels belittled in himself
in front in front of his kids in front
of his family and this woman does
she submits performatively so she's like
oh yeah I'll cook for you I'll cook but
when they have an agreement and he's
like I need you to move right she's like
nah that's not a good enough reason I'm
moving left and that constantly happens
they go through therapy and that's
essentially the Crux of it she's like I
wasn't raised that way
um like my mum wasn't like that I'm not
gonna be like that whatever so and this
man is now happy she is not happy you're
like for Duty sake the family stay
together anyway yeah and I think
marriage should be based on
sustainability like can she sustain that
long term no I would say until the kids
are 18 I would do everything I could to
figure it out until the kids are 18.
what just give up all like sense of
morality and happiness and like even if
it is jeopardizing with your mental
health and like even things like that
like just stay what do you mean all
sense of morality I need you to be like
he was saying about like oh that's how
my mother was raised like if it's going
against your morals in there like like
not forcing you but like asking you to
be someone that you're not like that's
you're giving up all sense
I will give Will Smith a divorce
I will grant that manager base your
relationship off your parents
relationship and if you watch your mum
or your dad constantly belittle
themselves and constantly let themselves
get walked over you're going to let
yourself get walked over because
if you're that gender because it's more
likely to be the woman you're gonna
think oh it's okay it's more likely to
be the woman because like domestic
violence you're more likely to be
domestically abused especially most most
um domestic violence is two-sided like a
lot of girls claim domestic violence but
they hit first okay um and you're
actually more likely to be in a domestic
violence um where if it's one-sided
abuse like women are more likely to be
in uh more likely to hit men one-sided
than what men are to hit women okay fine
well whatever gender is your whatever
gender gets belittled you're if you're
that gender You're Gonna Let Yourself Go
walked over like that so do you think
people should just like never get
divorced is that like your position yeah
like do you think divorce should just be
like illegal like yeah
okay we'll sniff a divorce you said that
like you said that they should try their
hardest was Johnny Depp married I'd give
that man a divorce too okay you're like
in some situations divorce is legitimate
you're acknowledge
in front of God you said you made your
vows in front of God and let's face it
in the UK for richer report for sickness
so much
to you not not to people wait wait wait
wait wait not to people of Faith but
statistically but this is the as a
country we have belonging but not
believing true true however however
that's why marriage is outdated that's
like why we're in a post-meritable
society that's why that wait wait that's
why people are getting married less and
less and less but what's people's
justification that they're saying the
marriage isn't walking out because they
can't say any more God God wants me to
do this what do they say to themselves
when they're unhappy and they're in a
situation it's about my kids
there are situations where divorce is
acceptable to you of course yeah okay
but here's my point
do you not think the two people involved
in that marriage are the best people to
judge when that situation has arrived
yeah I think if that was true I don't
think it would be a 50 divorce rate
I don't think
I remember one reason wait I don't think
the number one reason would be
financially yes but that doesn't exist
in the vacuum though like there is other
things like that that changes when you
add more details like are they more
educated than it like I think it lowers
or if they're if they come from a
two-family home where everyone is still
married then it goes up like it's there
are things that change yeah it's bad so
it's not like you know every time you
get married it's a coin flip it depends
on your personal situation and things
going on some situations that are better
and worse true yeah and there's some
situations you're like you should get
divorced in your mind yeah exception's
not the rule I don't I don't think 50 of
marriages should end in divorce and my
whole point but like you're missing my
point because you're trying you're
trying to like get me no no no I'm not
I'm not no no wait wait and it's the
whole point is that we have a me me
culture where it's me and my happiness
before the family and where I think I
should put my feelings before the family
in extreme situations sure I believe in
divorce Will Smith I don't of Johnny
Depp was married to that woman but I'll
give you both divorces I'll get wait
wait I'll give you both divorces but in
general it's like we just have such a
selfish like modern women are selfish
yes and and it's weight and and it's
about me before my family and I just
think that's wrong but it's reflective
of the society we like in the UK in
America we have very capitalist
societies and that is individualism and
if you were in a more socialist society
where it was more about the community
then you would find families wouldn't
splurb us often and and the fact is it's
not just women and like men and women
equally are because they're interested
women are the ones leaving women leave
70 to 80 of them is much more willing to
go through wait when women leave 70 to
80 percent of the time 90 of their
college educated if anything I think
women have become more selfish because
we're built out of every bad decision
wait yes
wait wait no I'll tell you yeah because
every time we make a bad decision we're
bailed out if we're bad with our money
there's women's shelters if we sleep
around there's birth control if we get
pregnant we can have an abortion wait if
we if we don't get the abortion and we
get married they can we can divorce them
and take half no if we or we can put the
kid on child support
not Ted as well
um when it comes to marriage
that there's almost no incentive for a
man to leave
um more often than not there are men who
just he who are still breathing about
dying everything as we're speaking right
now so it's like
what you lose from a man leaving the
marriage in comparison to women even
marriage it's just it's more
incentivized for women to leave it's
just facts as a man a woman's going to
take off your money and you probably
won't have access to your kids that's
why it's cheaper to keep it you know
yeah most men will literally rather just
like just fade
one in four marriages or one in four
marriages are sexless yeah oh and like
let's be honest is it the women not
sleeping with the matter the men not
sleeping so why why are we even so at
this point from what everybody is saying
I'm hearing it from all sides
I feel like in today's society the
safest and probably healthiest thing for
you to do is to have an agreement
between a man and a woman who agree on
the values that they want to put on
their child to grow feel to be whatever
human they want that child to be and
leave it as that possession love
marriage all of these things are
fantasies that realistic in today's age
don't have as much standing what does
have standing is a respectful
relationship with somebody and that
doesn't mean you have to live together I
would love listen I swear to God I would
love to to be able to have a man that
will give me my children but he does not
have to have me and we can still
cooperate and we can still raise the
children together but you have your own
house at my own house Daddy has his own
space he likes his house and Daddy's
house is your house I have my own space
at my house and Mommy sounds is also
your house and Daddy can come to my
house Mommy can go to his house because
we're good friends we get on really well
we have a lot for each other we want it
like that because I don't think I can I
don't want I don't think I would be
happy for the rest of my life and I
would be able to actually give the kind
of love and the kind of good energy and
positivity to my child when I have
somebody else attached to me that
because in so many ways because we're
different people just in general they
will drag my energy down sometimes and I
don't think that you're fighting your
happiness before the kids
if it goes back to like what I've been
saying you're still interested I'm going
I'm teaching listen I'm going the other
way my happiness and this is thing I
know this very well because I know when
my mom came when we came to England I
remember my mom had to work in all these
things my mom's happiness was something
that was very important to us seeing her
struggle seeing her suffering that way
seeing it to go through all of these
things was really impactful on us you're
not in control of your emotions no of
course I can be in control of my
emotions but if I'm happy okay so then
can you can you put on a happy front for
your kids uh the thing is you can put in
a happy friend for your kids but this is
the thing about kids that most people
tend to forget children are not stupid
do you understand exactly you can always
catchable you can always know when
things are not okay with mommy or daddy
things change your behavior will change
no matter how much you try to pretend
and fake it it will always be visible
and that's why I would say nowadays save
yourself and actually be with somebody
not be with them forever but have a good
contract a good relationship with that I
think that's the future of dating as
long as I don't think it's going to be
the two house thing it Britain's too
high in London but but I do think that
like long term it's going to be like
long-term relationships outside of
marriage and if people do get married
they'll date for longer first yeah where
it seems to be going I think that's
what's going to be because these days
the way that we're talking about women
at this men and that then nobody's
trusting anybody to actually have that
commitment for Life the only way you can
have a commitment for life is if you
take away the possession and the me and
you together and you make it about the
child so it doesn't even matter if
you're together or not because what you
love the most is that kid and you want
that kid to grow happy so you get on and
it's reflected in all aspects of life
you don't have a job for life anymore
you you have a few jobs and whichever
job gives you the most money you stick
with like it's not
it I don't think I think the family is
just what's it just shows what's
happening in society it's just a
reflection I beg to differ
um reason being is that
um
I think once you've once you have a
child
it's not it's no longer about you it's
really really about the children and if
it just means that you just take it as a
job
and in front of the children because
what children are like sponges right and
whatever you're referring to is whatever
your mum exposed to you or whatever your
father exposed to you and this if if
you're once you have children in my
opinion you have to do the best that you
can do to give them the best possible
upbringing
in certain cases at your expense because
as statistics suggest
that extra effort prevents a child from
entering a prison system and prevents a
child from going through certain
development stages that they don't need
to go through these kind of things so I
just think like once you have a child in
the picture of marriage or not the child
should be the priority irrespective of
where you stand you the child comes
first before you in my opinion so that's
that's pretty much what I was saying
earlier like if if you're together and
you've got a kid and the relationship's
not working out then just co-inhabit you
can live together and be roommates and
live in the same house as long as the
kids see the the unit you you eat
together at a dinner table all that kind
of stuff
no but no no no but if it's an
arrangement like you both agree to like
it's not
no but listen it's not working between
us yeah
somewhere else have a separate room just
just let us out just let the children
exactly if it's not working out we can
come to an
Arrangements
we're not saying that's the ideal
situation but I'm just I'm putting like
if I was in that situation and I think
Hmm I know it's better for my kids if
the mom and the dad are in the home and
if for a couple years I just have to be
in separate bedrooms and figure out how
to deal with this guy I don't like like
I'm gonna do it I chose to make a kid
with him if I didn't want to do that I
shouldn't have chosen to make a kid with
him but Cory Nobody Until the kids are
at least of age to kind of understand
when you start splitting up the home and
the kids are like under 10 confuses them
they start thinking it's their fault the
worst thing for children is to not have
a mom and a dad in a house I agree with
what I forgot your name what you're
saying Pierre and what Paul's saying
it's the worst thing and I feel like if
you didn't want to have kids of that
person then you should have been more
careful but you need to think about the
children because their childhood really
shapes the way they are especially like
not having a dad and I feel like you
just need to firm some things and
happiness
it comes and goes can I ask you a
question would you rather your mum and
dad were together but you watch your dad
tree your mom like like I would rather
my mum and dad be together but like some
people have suggested different ways of
going about things rather than like
someone running away like but with that
with the ideology of like cohabitation
and like just living together and being
unhappy and like sleeping in separate
beds and like just putting on a front
for the whole family like he said the
ideology of like kids like being a
sponge they absorb like what's going on
around them they are they're not stupid
they are seeing what's happening your
parents are sleeping in separate beds
that literally as they grow up that like
tells them like oh that like like stops
them from being intimate with Partners
later in life because they don't see
this intimacy between their parents the
two people that like learning from and
living with and staff and they're seeing
like this unhappiness like whether it's
a front or not like they are like seeing
that your mom and your dad like aren't
happy together so how is this like how
is that better for the kids what's
what's the better better alternative
wait wait they're inseparate they're in
separate houses and then they get to
meet their girlfriends and boyfriends
over the years so I think you should
meet their other partners but I think
you should be able to see your parents
happy I think you should see your
parents respecting their own boundaries
and it teaches individualism rather than
dependency
but marriage and family isn't about
individualism and that's my whole point
it's a me me culture but you said to
yourself you said that this is a
post-marriage society so why should we
be trying to backtrack on society like
this is the way society's growing like
we just have to accept and move on I
think yeah I think it's regardless of
whether it's for the better of society
it's better for the individual like or
you should really care about is your
self-worth and your self happiness I
think marriage as an institution is dead
I still think there will be families but
I I think
um yeah as legally as an institution I
think it's dead but how would you feel
if you saw your your daughter or your
son in a relationship they weren't happy
in you wouldn't save them because I mean
I would I would rather see if I if I had
a daughter let's say that was with a guy
didn't like yeah I probably would have
warned her not to have a kid with him
I'd like to say I probably would have
she were women right we do it anyway so
so she has a kid with him I warned you
not to do it now you made your bed like
I I would just say lie in it lie in it
until he's 18. especially especially in
life before you lose outside of abuse
sorry go ahead you lose so much value
for yourself though when you're with
someone that you know isn't good for you
or you know it is I don't know what like
you lose value for yourself like I don't
really care with them but it's like a
punishment yeah yeah it's a it's a
you're it's a punishment you chose
poorly but I'm I'm a big right but I'm
saying I'm saying be accountable for
what you chose you picked it you made
that you made that choice in half the
weight wait wait and
half the time women pick men they know
would not be good Fathers
I
kind of get where you're coming from
like respect the institution family
first I always get that but like so what
if and I suppose this also goes to the
cohabiting thing because I get it like
you're still trying to make it work even
though you're not sleeping together like
you're there's a separation but there's
this idea that we're still here you can
be friends for the kids yeah so but what
happens if you can see that and I'm not
trying to trap you up I'm genuinely
asking like if you can see this
situation you together even cohabiting
cohabitating you get along so poorly
even when trying that you can see it's
making the children unhappy at that
point then I would say yeah you got to
separate people at least try at least I
give will a division
those kids are happy bro
I've seen it I've seen it I've seen
family members literally live together
for like five years and they weren't
together together but they just lived in
the same house and they slept in
separate rooms and the aisle fall as
even as a childlike why why are they
still together but it showed like after
a while for me personally it just showed
strength yeah and then
after the the situation in that period
where they whatever was going on between
them I think it lasted like five years
maybe even longer but they ended up
coming back together afterwards and for
me it's actually witnessing that was a
beautiful thing
can I couldn't go ahead I just wanted to
put a total spin on it something that
sort of related but unrelated what about
I say girls women however you want to
describe them the ones that get pregnant
on purpose to keep the man
yeah so I I've been waiting to try and
get my voice heard here
it does happen I know women that have
done it I know man that I've done that
of course yeah but but
yeah purposely coming inside a girl yeah
to get her pregnant so that she'll stay
with her wow
but a woman can still get rid of it the
man doesn't have a choice yeah but the
man can pressure them into keeping it
you don't have to yeah men influence
women
but you still literally don't have to
all right guys let her let her finish
yeah so this is this is a big thing and
um women will do it on private person it
doesn't matter what age you are what
background they think that's the way to
keep a man to retain a relationship to
perhaps even force a man into marriage
for some years that may not even last
and where you were talking about the
parents staying together
if that's what happens then then man
feels they've got no other choice but to
okay I've got to marry this girl she's
pregnant how long is that going to last
because they're then forced into the
situation they actually don't want to
live together
but then they've understand the
responsibility of co-parenting you know
if if the woman has done that and the
and their father has tried and they're
right gonna marry you or I'm going to
move him with you we're having a child
together I don't like what you've done
you know you forced me into it but I'm
gonna try
that's that's that's an exception I'd
say yeah
yeah it's a good question though they're
forced into living it living with each
other
for the sake of the children where you
said the children have to stay together
was he dating her first was he like
dating her was it a suggestion that
there was
um
one of I say one of the gyms that I used
to go to
um
the the girl got pregnant on for purpose
thinking that would enhance a
relationship force them into marriage
and being able to keep the relationship
she was like dating him yeah they were
dating and
um they split up and all I can say is
you know there are exceptions uh the
most amazing father ever he took up his
responsibilities he absolutely adores
his son but he was forced into that
situation but all that did is you know
they end up breaking up did they did
they get married and then separate or no
they just agreed that they couldn't make
it work that they weren't interested in
each other they just decided to raise
his child but like separately they were
raising the child separately she forced
him into situation to try and retain the
relationship yeah that's an exception I
think I think the main the main thing
the main point here is like taking
accountability of your purposeful
actions but what happened to the
relationship like what happened to the
relationship after like she like
basically baby trapped him like it broke
down yeah it broke it down did they
decide to like Force themselves to live
together
exactly no no no none of that she forced
the situation she forced a situation
which obviously he was not happy about
but despite the situation and then
breaking up he stepped up as the one of
the most responsible amazing fathers
that you could ever meet whilst living
separately though yeah yeah okay
most of my words like most like the
majority of men yeah like we think
logically right and we go out to cover
the basis I want to make sure that my
child can eat I want to make sure that
my child has a reef over there and I
want to make sure that my child's on
education the other Comfort bits we may
not all be so good at that but I'll say
that in no such situations speak until
women who are thinking of doing this
right now to trap a man that is the best
way to terminate your relationship
because that guy right there he may have
he may with patience he may have he may
have loved you for life right yeah but
trapping a man is just it's almost the
most certain most surest way to create
an enemy of like that guy would hate
hate hates her existence but loves his
child I'm saying so it's a thing where
like that's that's it's it's an
unproductive strategy that's your way of
getting love and it doesn't work because
it's not sustainable because you haven't
built that foundation and all of a
sudden you're in a really high pressure
situation where you're like oh my God
that's a horrible horrible thing you
know what it is that's that's I'm really
conflicted on that because I don't
really like rewarding bad behavior but
at the same time like I think it's about
the kids first I don't know because you
know what it is men are more accountable
for their actions so a man in that
situation is going to think do you know
what I'm not in her so
oh God I look after the kids you know
what I mean
I did it
there's also the point I mean I mean I'm
talking about this as a woman and I'm
I'm almost siding with a man talking
about this woman because I know people
that have done this where the woman on
purpose
will miss taking her pill and they're
you know whatever else she's doing she
will make the situation so it actually
happens how do you like did they tell
you this or how do you know they did it
well if we're talking about my um the
guy I know from the gym I don't know
what happened there but I do my most
recent ex
um you know we kept going back you know
on off on off and in between one of the
times where he end up dating someone
else then we got back together she
actually did that
she claimed she was taking her pill and
there was all these sorts of things
um she tried to trap him
yeah she's stopped She yeah this is this
is my ex
um yeah she tried to chat for him and
she felt pregnant and um
he and I ended up getting back together
again for a millionth time
um and then
sadly which I would never wish on any
man or any woman
um
she missed she miscarried but
um things I I don't I can't say I'm not
going to go into medical things why
things happen but I do know that she was
my last say taking uh I don't know what
my last time you do she she was taking
drugs am I allowed to say oh God I don't
know what I can say sure you can talk
about drugs
she she was taking a certain type of
drug
um
oh I can only guess I can't say the deaf
enough but I I could say that what she
was taking and her lifestyle and the
alcohol and the things that she was
doing may have this is May but
necessarily contributed to that stress
on the body will induce her and abortion
I mean there's a there's a reason Drake
puts hot sauce in his condo come on like
there's a reason like girls do that yeah
I didn't know you guys do you think that
a girl that lies to a man about being on
the pill
um and gets pregnant should be pursued
for fraud
no but it's just it's disgusting it's
just it's disgusting behavior
let's say let's say it could be proven
like she admitted I told him I was
taking birth control yeah
and pretends to wear a condom and he's
not same thing that is essay so if you
pretend to take the phone you're not
that's I say yeah you'll have his own
name but it's definitely need I think
again uh why did I decide to agree once
with pearl because now I seem to agree
with him on a lot I do think that's
something turning you no you're not
turning me I think we're just finding
common ground because there's gray areas
in the world as you know but I do think
that there's a lot of um things that in
the relationship between women and men
where women are actually favored and
they do then kind of get away with
taking with not taking accountability
for certain stuff so that is why I would
then just say from the moment go
pick somebody that will be a good father
to your children and a good man to you
and that doesn't mean he needs to be
with you that's all you need to do in
fact forget about the good man just let
him be a good father that's all you need
because that kid forget about your
relationship with him don't how would
the fraud thing work like just like
thinking out like uh and it makes sense
but is it like would the fraud payments
cancel out
yeah and then what would happen with the
baby
um I would guess the only way you could
prove it is a text if she told someone
yeah
I don't that's I would guess
um it's quite common but then I just
come to control it you said visually
recording her like what visually
recording you're taking yeah bro I have
no idea
a girl admitted it on national TV she
asked if she asked it was at a talk show
a couple years ago and she asked the
host if she should I think it was one
Wendy Williams maybe or maybe a
different host
and she basically asked them if she
would she could stop taking the pill she
she her husband doesn't want more kids
she does should she stop taking the pill
and just get pregnant and literally they
told her yes if the if the mind's on
showing like I don't know like if you're
that unsure that your wife is going to
do that he didn't want any more kids and
like I don't know I don't know the
situation but yeah he either gets a
vasectomy or he just starts wearing corn
dogs
I don't think most men expect their wife
to death
he's watching TV he's like what if
you're managing that kind of thing it's
entrapment why are you there like if
you're like you you have an idea she
could do this so I'm gonna get the snip
or I think I'm like bro like why are you
with this stuff you shouldn't have to
think like that but you know what I
think on this subject yeah talking as a
guy I think there's there's also needs
to be
um I guess more accountability from from
from from both sides because I follow a
lot of This falls on the women 100
um because you know if you don't if you
don't want to take like if you don't
want to take pills then what you do I
mean like most guys would not go through
the same equivalent and there are those
options so I feel like it's about
balancing that in a way because yes I do
agree if you say on the pill and you
don't take the pill even the pill itself
is 100 so I mean so I think it's a bit
foolish to rely on a pearl on a pill
and with the expectation that you will
never have a child yeah and this just
opens up the the idea should men have to
kind of do something about contraception
other than just like wearing under them
because it's all the responsibilities on
the women when men could have temporary
vasectomies we got like we got 40 one
forms a birth control
you could get you can I don't you can I
don't you can get an
iuds from what exactly then where then
have the guys you sleep with wear
condoms yeah but a condoms don't know as
well okay then get a plan B yeah but why
does it have to always follow me like
why does it always have to be my body
yes we have the freedom it comes with
responsibility but men could also just
get a temporary vasectomy and it's
completely reversed celibacy is the
safest bet thank you
okay you think you think a vasectomy is
the same thing as birth control
hasn't got a side effect and me taking
loads of forms of birth control I could
gain weight I could be emotional I could
feel just like you could be celibate
come on celibacy is 100 yeah also we
also have the option of abortion we're
the ones that put them on child support
keep your pants locked men and women
keep your pants locked put a padlock
this is my set been my saying for a year
for a year or two now to anybody who
asked me put a padlock on your pants
that's a new saying padlock your pants
answer as well you could only just have
sex with people you are okay having a
child yeah
like but that temporary vasectomy I mean
yeah
he's like we're not doing the padlocks
and you you can't just have a tent
Rivers next to me that doesn't make you
feel any different exactly why do why do
guys have the sexual Liberation to [ __ ]
whoever they want sorry
that woman has to worry about the
repercussions of having sex with her
whoever she wants whatever she has a
child because of that like she just
wanted to go out and have sex and have
fun because those consequences with the
mannequin not in her and then just
wait he could be on child support for 18
years there are men that have committed
suicide over the amount of child support
that they pay they're financially
incentivized in court to overestimate
the cost that it takes to raise a child
so that they can hook men on child
support they actively had sex on them
I'm not talking about like long-term
thing I'm talking about like hook up
situations like they actively if they're
having sex with her and like you you
like [ __ ] in her and you actively did
that and she has to go the next morning
get the morning after pill or if she's
too late for that she has to get the
abortion maybe you don't know him like
what repercussions does he okay but she
she gets that she gets that choice man
if they if they're both doing the same
thing right they're both irresponsible
in this situation so the woman gets to
have the freedom to get the plan b or
the abortion he has no choice like if he
got her pregnant he doesn't believe in
abortion what choice does he have none
if she wants to put him on child support
what choice does he have nothing
she has to live with those consequences
so she has to get pregnant she has to
know she could give it up for adoption
my mom got pregnant at 17 she gave the
kid okay not the purposes of getting
pregnant I've been getting quite yeah it
can be quite a strain in your quality
but then you can get an abortion even
that is
you're just asking to undo biology you
can't how about this yeah
I mean sorry I was just saying that as a
comeback to like you all saying like
just be celibate then but like what if
you do just want to like go out and have
sex
you can do that I say fine but if you're
gonna do that I would say get an IUD
right
the contraceptive falls on the woman
yeah
she's the one that has to give birth and
stuff and she has to deal with like
being pregnant but why does
contraception have to fall on her when
all these contraceptive methods most
likely like they call cause like
hormonal imbalances and they have side
effects on her whereas the man most men
are more likely to look for one like one
night stands and stuff and they can just
go and [ __ ] this girl and then he
doesn't have to do it one of the three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year under 30. so it's
not and women are having more sex than
men yeah and even male contraception
that has been trialled has had side
effects of female contraception no so
the the issue like a lot of times they
say that but that's not true no it's
they were sterilized from it and I think
one or two guys died so it was a pretty
you know yeah but also death is a side
effect of some contraceptions they do
say it goes right inside makes you right
but but I think it was like a sample of
a thousand uh roughly or maybe it was a
thousand or less I if I'm it's off the
top of my head but it wasn't a big
sample size so if you're taking birth
control and you know it was one out of a
thousand you probably I wouldn't do it
but it is true why do women have to take
responsibility
okay okay let's let's go from the
beginning every every step of the way
women have Choice men don't okay so let
me let me just I know I know okay wait
please let me let me finish this and
I'll explain so if we both want to have
sex after the sex men lose the choice
because women have the choice to be on
birth control actually before even
before women have the choice to be on
birth control or not that's our choice
right we have the choice to track when
we're ovulating we know when we're
ovulating they don't that's a choice
right we have the choice to go get the
plan B he can't make you take it that's
a choice we have the choice to say hey
if outside of essay I don't have sex
without condoms that's a choice then if
I if I get pregnant you can get an
abortion that's a choice
him being on child support for 18 years
no choice
no choice he goes to jail if he doesn't
pay it here I think they seize your
assets in the US they go to jail
[Music]
it's Peak hmm but
I just say just be selective I'm not
gonna lie I'm not on any birth control
why because I'm selective and I'm
careful and I'm not out there like that
do you see what I mean I'm natural and
I'm not going to put things in my body
that going to ruin me so I'm taking the
responsibility for the situation I've
put myself in and I'm not doing the
things that are going to put me at risk
it's really that simple you just got to
make better decisions for yourself and
we need to stop talking about oh men and
women make bad decisions for yourself
men make better decisions maybe pick
better women women that seem to be maybe
a little bit more mentally stable don't
just go off of what one of the West is
great or not the West that the East is
great I remember the past four I've
heard great things about Brazil for the
guys be careful well actually let me
know because I'll get canceled all men
have to do is just wrap it up though
simple
I hear stories and I'm like oh wow then
but but like the whole point is that we
have more choice in it so it comes with
being more responsible but you don't you
don't even have to pay for Condoms all
you have to do is go to your doctor go
to your sexual health clinic whether you
are a woman or a man you can go to your
clinic and saying I need some supplies
they will give you a nice little paper
bag yes I've had that before and they
will give that to you whether you are a
man or a woman so there's no excuses
even as a woman if you don't want to
take the pill and you want to use a
condom
yeah to have some have supplies for free
yeah I think I didn't add it on to what
you're saying sorry
um because I know there's different
certain women don't like having rubber
um
downstairs and stuff right with the
condom situation I get that but I feel
like
a lot of these decisions that we've been
discussing is just being a short-term
interaction with a long-term consequence
that a lot of people don't want to take
accountability for
how about investing if you if you're not
comfortable with the idea of celibacy or
or having sex to procreate investing
more time and educating yourself in ways
to naturally
um I guess um reduce the the possibility
of having a child you know as you're
saying about cycles for example or men
training themselves to to to uh to pull
out or you know I mean um retention all
these kind of things
pre-coming what I'm saying like there's
there are things that you can do before
you have that interaction and and risk
it so I mean risk it long terms I mean
and I don't think there's enough of a
conversation around different exercises
you can do to basically self-con
um
basically natural conception techniques
of fun and women's yeah cycle for
example and you can only get pregnant
like three to five roughly exactly yeah
yeah yeah and more often than not I
could be wrong but do correct me women
but like
my understanding is from my experience
I've when women have been more attracted
to me I've been when they've been moved
more fertile yeah there's something but
yeah so chances are more of it falls on
you women because you know when you're
fertile we don't so it's like when
you're having these fertile experiences
you're increasing the likelihood of even
having a child so why not just get
accustomed to having
sex when you're not fertile and reducing
that that possibility that rather than
just saying you're not it's less
enjoyable when you're not far tired
enjoyment
yeah it's like it's like you guys want
to do whatever you want and have no
responsibility yeah it's the same thing
if we're gonna have all the
responsibility I'd have all the
responses
the artificial woman to my body so it's
now my fault
that's the part I'm a bit confused
okay guys guys guys it has to be one at
a time so most of the girls I've been
with outside of my relationship they
have insisted I wear a condom so it's
like this inequity you're talking about
options isn't it like doesn't a condom
solve it like a guy yeah yeah a fair
enough condom solves it but with like
some guys don't want to wear a condom to
be honestly don't have sex with them
simple some women a lot of women don't
actually want condoms as well don't they
don't want guys wearing a condom so it's
a thing where like if you're concerned
about this and you know when you're
fertile I promise you right yeah if you
tell a guy I am very fertile and I'm
very likely to be pregnant over the next
week
he will he will himself come forward and
say I will be the contraception I will
be celibate I promise you it sounds
funny but if you as women I should tell
men when you're fertile because a guy it
doesn't matter it's a day John Wayne if
it means that like that 18 years and
wait in five days and we still get to do
what we've got to do
it's it's logical you know my point
isn't that men have no responsibility I
I don't think it's wise to shoot up at
random girls that you don't know I don't
think that's smart
but but the point is that like we have
10 choices they have one maybe now
actually if we're gonna count 41 forms
of birth control we probably have like
50 choices and they have they have like
a vasectomy and condoms that's it why do
we make more forms for men
I think I think there's either two
theories as to why there's no birth
control for men
um one is that women don't want to give
up power
and that too is that it's harder
biologically like scientists can't
figure out a way I do not believe that
you can create semen men can create
semen throughout their whole life women
can make what you are born with the
amount of energy right now women have a
hundred percent of reproductive power
over who was born a hundred percent
women are in complete control even the
odds so I I agree I think there should
be a male birth control yeah but it's
it's it's the fact that our society
isn't isn't putting money into that
outside isn't focused on that because
apparently we don't have to deal thank
you it's patriarchal think like women
have to deal with all this responsible
is that patriarchal when women make 70
to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions women women have more power
than men I would argue because we're the
ones bailed out of every bad decision I
would say as well actually as women the
you know we are the ones that get
pregnant we are the ones that will grow
the baby inside of us and therefore I
believe that actually if you are going
to put yourself in that situation you do
have to take
um account of that that power that you
do have to bring life into this because
the man cannot so he will never
understand what it means so he'll just
do anything willy-nilly doesn't think
about the consequences as deep because
it's not going to go inside of him I I
asked one of my friends I said to him oh
he just had a baby I said yo bro how'd
you feel you had a baby did you cry he
said actually no I don't know how I felt
because the baby was inside my girl for
all these months she's had a head start
on knowing the child or it's because she
is the woman she has the baby I just
added to it so I didn't really think
about what it felt because I still had
to get to know the baby simply for the
fact that it is us so I would say for
sure I me as a woman I take
responsibility if I was to get pregnant
by now I would not go in I didn't want
the baby I want to go to my man and do
whatever man come in front be like yo
listen I'm pregnant what we gonna do
I'll be like okay I made a mistake I
[ __ ] up what am I gonna do that's it
so you if you don't want to be in that
situation just put that where am I going
to do before the mistake even happens
because you're gonna be the one with the
baby if we talk about the fact that the
women is the usually the one that stays
with the child because we're more
nurturing then again it just goes the
parents don't give it to men that's it
so you actually as a woman now in that
situation understand your power actually
as when we have a lot of power the only
part the only problem with us is that we
make the wrong choices that's it we only
realize the power that we have when
we're using it for the wrong reasons or
when we have lost it when we've made
mistakes that's instrumental you said we
we have we make the wrong choices
yeah I would say so uh
what happened to you every time I talk
on this podcast yeah I talk from
experience because I know that not only
the choices I've made the choices a lot
of my friends have made I also talk
about men because I also see a lot of
the mistakes they've made but when it
comes to this when it comes to this sort
of situation I know the power that I
have and I know the responsibility that
I have I will not run away from it to
say all equality because this is one of
those one things actually that is not
equal between women and men at all a man
cannot give birth to a child we can that
is completely different so we have that
power we need to take responsibility for
it I would I want to add for men as well
watching this
just download one of those free apps
like be around like download one of
those free apps use a rubber as long as
you can until you figure out her cycle
it tell you or tell you when she's like
pretty much when she's fertile
make sure that you've got a rubber on if
you want to be active then
and outside of that there's there's you
know there's ways to work around this
naturally you might even do both jump
relationship contraception like on a
pill or whatever and condoms if you want
to be ultra safe yeah that's it I mean
it's it's there's enough out there's
more than enough out there but
communication everyone's saying you know
like why isn't there movies like The the
stuff that was that's already out there
people are only using probably three out
of the how many 40 something options you
know so I feel like it really it really
falls back on option three for men track
your girl's cycle that's it guys
literally that I did that myself and
it's a thing where I I went in that draw
which I mean I wasn't into um until
that's um you know the the actual I had
to take risks so you have to take risks
not necessarily rules calculated
calculated calculator calculated
execution I'll be scared out there but
I'm just saying that ultimately I didn't
know the day there's nature app playing
and you if you actually understand
nature for it is as you're saying is you
know the whole fertility thing is a
couple days in a month right is that
correct yeah
so if you've got three to five days in a
month right you've got about 30 days in
a month right yeah and you're the nasty
and not have consequences sorry to do
the nasty and I have Concepts
like this he's in a relationship clearly
no I'm not in a relationship but the
point I'm making is that three two four
wait is it three to five days right
let's let's call it five let's call it a
week
yeah but what I'm saying is that let's
call it a week here yeah let's call it a
week right yeah and you've got three
other weeks in the month right yeah and
one of them you're extremely um if
you're both aware of when that first
when that fertile for me it doesn't make
sense why why you wouldn't want to know
when when you're when your woman when
you do if you don't want to be a parent
it doesn't make sense to me why you
wouldn't want to know
when when your partner's fertile because
as a woman that's the highest that's
literally the most certain time that you
can get pregnant right so if you're not
taking accountability for that I'm sorry
but I feel like more that percentage
falls on you and as a man You're Not
Innocent in this because that is
something that you can learn I
understand that women when they they
they there aren't other women it it
moves a couple days here and now I get
that but ultimately just find out when
her time of the month is what's the app
called
obviously that would work in a situation
um in a relationship what would you say
to the people who want to have one night
stands and you can't really I want to
say you can't have that conversation up
front but it's like
condoms yeah
especially especially for a one-night
stand you've got to wrap it up like
literally you you're you're welcome
pregnant
is not even the first thing I'll come to
my mind
Jesus Christ she
cries
mate you shouldn't be asking that
question
those activities
okay there's a lot of people I'll add
that to men's choices pull that's a one
choice
yeah pull out or don't pull out oh whoa
best form of concentration best form of
con I can't even say it
celibacy do I mean like literally it's
what it is
I mean this way isn't it this way what
you're saying about celibacy I can't
even say that word now exactly what I
said I'm gonna coin that phrase I'm
gonna I'm gonna copyright it padlock
your pants
lock your pants make that go viral
padlock your pants okay I'm gonna I
haven't read super chats once this show
yeah
um I I'm gonna be honest chat I don't
think I can read all of these These are
too long
um I'm gonna do ten dollars or more I'm
gonna read I'm sorry I'm sorry chat um
okay Cree
just watched another episode earlier
today about the male contraceptive
denelva should remember they make it
they made it and stats and States why it
doesn't exist
um Mike Sinatra um no disrespect but why
is the pink haired guy there um he plays
for the other team and usually people
that live the alternative lifestyle
don't bring perspective to a
conversation about us
um Jeff Cruz thank you for the Super
chataya Why do you think Society is
going in a good direction when School
shooters why do you think Society is
going in a good direction when School
shooters didn't exist before this new
wave of progress people are dismissed
and having an easy life for having two
parents in society that's the goal
um Clifford Reigns Jr the panel is a
perfect example that the new generation
has no people skills the world is
entering a dark future e love the show
if you go on of or corn and have a body
count of one 1 or higher your access to
high value men will go to zero 304s will
always be 304 as people only get angry
by the truth Andres Garcia keep up the
good work Clifford range Pearl where did
you find these betas um you wait Pearl
where did you find these damn betas you
tell who die alone the amount of need to
be from women and the betas is amazingly
sad top G Andrew Tate is Right marriage
causes divorce in a the UK and the UK
divorce the man is going to lose around
70 or more he will lose more than half
because the judge will want the man to
clear her debts and give her a big house
deposit maintain her standard of living
Etc I lost 70 percent Rumble rocks High
pearly tell my beautiful half Somalian
sister we love you no matter what proud
of how you have less to say about the
delusional ideas PS feminism ideas
keeping a smart one smile more though
Ray patson a pearl you are the next
Kevin Samuels Pearl or big up to Erin
pizzi on the topic of DV do you know um
Professor Janice Flamingo watch Flamingo
files on feminism on YouTube's please
react to her YouTube videos and
interview her send me the link on
Instagram I do look at stuff to react to
when people send it to me on Instagram
just say something
big yellow is already brainwashed by
feminism instead of seeing her seeing
parents fight and then resolve things
now women are just leaving seventy
percent of the time when they're not
happy which they won't Define um see
Dumbledore for the me Society isn't
growing it's rotting um the panel is a
perfect example of the raw Miguel and
Naya your happiness is the pro is your
problem not your kids or your parents
kids are not dumb yes of course but
you're but you're teaching them
commitment responsibility making
sensible choices things you that things
you should have done but choose not to
Obi-Wan classic notice how the women
answer immediately after every response
this is what destroys marriage they
don't argue to find a compromise they
argue for their own selfish need to be
right Joseph Metzler
capitalism promotes marriage because
that's who you build wealth in a
socialism it is socialism that marries
women to the government and needs at um
and needs people to function rasheem
McFadden new rule no kids before
marriage Chris to the 20 year old living
with her parents and giving life advice
please hear this money
so she can buy a razor for the pits
moblets marriage is a duty and not a
feeling if you are grown enough to marry
then you should be grown enough to
separate your problems from your kids
and let your kids be kids keep kids out
of grown folks issues Clifford range
this is a prime example of why modern
women will be alone because they are not
happy all the time the dude in the front
is back talking like a woman I'm looking
for extreme examples for the exceptions
um these are two dollars blue Baggins um
the ladies are losing their [ __ ] at the
thought of even trying to get along with
a Man Zero Fallout for every good story
of the stepdad there are horror stories
we always want to bring up the good
stories by probability you're going to
be the stepdad on Dad
um Black Ops no man wants to compete for
a woman's love with her kids from a
previous relationship she will always
put the kid before you which is good for
the child but bad for you beaten cheeks
what are these usernames
um girl on the black coat um tan pants
can't get over the fact that she is a
four next to these 25 year olds um
DMACC why is it so damn hard for women
to accept the fact that men like what
they like beaten cheeks again
women seeing young boys cannot get a
real man for their validation due to
normal realistic standards men men have
and the woman on the couch black coat
tan pants without the simps telling her
sweet nothings Al young guys only get
with older women because they're easier
than younger women
owl blonde hair on the couch I have a
house a wedding ring and a one-way
flight to New York whenever you're ready
I'm attracted to your femininity my love
I told you we get marriage requests on
this show sometimes are you going to New
York
um do you want to say your Instagram you
never know my Instagram is bexie Lucy X
Chris um the real reason you call
something baggage is because you view it
as baggage what the lady wants is for
people to not hold her accountable for
past mistakes that's why she gets
triggered and wants to take it personal
NSX I don't want to raise another man's
kids the same as you don't want to have
kids to a man that cannot protect and
provide Terrell Clark
stop trying to make these men accept
dating older women we have life and
relationship goals we don't want to fund
the lifestyle of a Woman twice our age
that's life accept it Terrell Clark
noticed the hypocrisy the old woman in
in the woman in black dated a 25 year
old and no one batted an eye and yet a
hypothetical situation with a 32 year
old man and 18 year old 18 year old girl
they are cringing and shaming him
um
or cosmok 2000 false there's no
manipulation high value men go for women
with less miles such as how it is Daniel
thank you passport thank you for the
passport bro episode I'm a 46 year old
male I left the world of Western dating
seven years ago went to the Philippines
found a woman and now I'm married five
years with two kids it's the best
decision I've ever made see Dumbledore
there is an amazing display of How
Deeply she has been indoctrinated to
believe things that are objectively
false and self-destructive yet she goes
to such lengths to defend her own
oh wait these are from last show okay
never mind
um okay it's getting late so can I say
one last thing quickly just on one of
the colors okay okay look at me look at
look at me please please quick right you
know what guys I think that you don't
understand how much women can benefit
from listening to gay men speak about
their sexual experiences because they
are the only ones that will be able to
speak to a woman tell her exactly what
it feels like to be a man just because
it's attracted to the same sex doesn't
mean that he's not a man so I've learned
a lot from gay men when it comes to how
men actually think about sex it's very
different yeah we invite everyone on the
show I see both sides of the story so
yeah I don't know why they're coming
with everyone on the show so
um so we're gonna do final thoughts
um and then so any final thoughts you
want to give any social media you want
to plug do now uh front there and then
second row
cool go ahead
final thoughts um I have learned a lot
tonight there are some things that I
knew already
um there are so many valuable opinions
views and thoughts here and I know we've
had obviously read out some of the
comments but
um I appreciate where we've been able to
discuss this
calmly what you know while I've got
wound up you know a few times and I just
wanted to go you know
um I've valued everyone's opinion behind
me in front of me around me and I think
we've had a really great discussion and
we can all learn something from each
other because the whole group of us have
been diverse tonight I just don't say
thank you and God bless everybody
oh that's so sweet thank you sister cool
hi guys denalva
d-i-n-a-l-v-a dot a o final thoughts are
I realize this um episode that recent
occurrences
um to do with this podcast have showed
me something I think that there's a lot
of women out there that are not thinking
straight and not putting their thoughts
together with the right construct so
from now on I'm going to sway a little
bit more towards the middle and see both
sides I'm looking for trouble with you
sisters as well because you've been
letting me down and I don't tie out
foreign
I just want to say thanks for having me
pal it was nice to listen to different
opinions again
um yeah I'll never be swayed from what I
think and
yeah that's about it really my Instagram
I've already said my website is
bexyleucy.com I write blogs I've got
ebooks to do with femininity and mindset
so if you're interested in that then
that's my website
okay my name is Hannah my Instagram is
Hannah Lackey l-e-c-k-y
and this experience has been interesting
I think that I've just learned everyone
needs to go into life with empathy and
treat people how they would like to be
treated and we need to stop using gender
as a means to attack each other and just
use it to collaborate like men and women
at the end of the day we want the same
thing we want peace we want Harmony we
want love let's stop blaming women let's
stop blaming men let's just collaborate
and find a bridge in the Middle where we
can all come to and be happy and Paul
thank you so much you've been so like
kind and receptive and like yeah thanks
for giving people this platform yeah
thanks for coming
um hi I just want to say thank you for
everyone like I know I feel like I've
it's been like quite enlightening just
hearing other people's opinions
um and it has actually opened like my
mind up to like other people's like
thoughts on the situations
um and I'll definitely be like more
receptive to what like other people
think from now
um and my Instagram is luca.f19
um yeah uh thank you for having me on
this dope experience enjoyed hearing
everyone's different perspectives uh
yeah that's pretty much it
yeah I just want to say thank you pal
for having me and the team and the panel
um I think my I just want to say that I
think we need just need to focus on the
solutions and address the problems
um as opposed to focusing on the
problems and
um yeah had an interesting experience
um gained some perspective and uh yeah
just wish everyone the best of luck
yeah
um I just think well thanks for having
me of course um been a great experience
it was good to hear everyone's different
opinions and see like we didn't actually
you know we didn't show any hands but we
could just meet the middle ground
um I just think that
to solve all of this we just need to
stop being so individualistic this is a
a Godless Society once we put something
aside in ourselves I think that we can
actually start building a community
um if you want to hit your boy up check
me on Instagram
um kid underscore dr223
firstly when I say big up PO we're
witnessing greatness with the show that
she's building uh secondly my name
if you want a bag of cougar grow a beard
they love it
we don't know
um okay a couple announcements before we
end the show um first of all thank you
for all the super chats tonight I'm
sorry if I couldn't read yours I really
try to read all of them but yeah it was
too many tonight I couldn't
um but good problem to have guys go
subscribe to the clips channels
um just probably clips and pearl daily
we have two different editors on the
account so you get two different types
of Clips they both like to clip you know
different types of content so go
subscribe to both of those
also sign up for our memberships if you
want to be a part of the live chat I do
keep an eye on the live chat during
shows so if you have you know sometimes
if I see something funny someone said
I'll read it so second tier the Discord
and the Vlogs I'm in the Discord now
sometimes I look at it for show topics
so um if you guys want to be a part of
like the topics that we actually pick
for the show sign up for the Discord
um if you want to see me freestyle
second tier behind the scenes Vlogs I
can freestyle and I do it in the second
tier third tier connect with me on
social media this means having access to
my inbox fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month I
recommend this if you want to start a
live show go follow my Instagram just
pearly things one um also we are on
Rumble now go subscribe to wife school
if you're at 304 you're a modern woman
you want to be more traditional we got
wife school coming for you go subscribe
to Wife School we're going to bring
wives from around the world
yeah to teach teach people how to be
wives anyways
um also other thing Pearl behind the
scenes I'm going to start streaming
again like I did my early subscribers
will know when I used to do these long
streams
um just like by myself reacting to
different stuff so go subscribe to Pearl
behind the scenes thank you for 750 000
subscribers yeah
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
our our goal is to get to a million
before New Year's and we might have a
little a special interview coming soon
so we might hit it we'll see we'll see
we'll special guest of who it is
um like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time wait wait
wait wait what's the elephant in the
room
[Music]
what's the elephant in the room that's
not fair curiosity really kills this cat
um there's no elephant in the room for
me
um he may think there's a different
elephants
thank you
all right bye guys